[Musique]
messieurs d'un bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle thinkerview nous sommes en
direct Cloud et Lydia Lydia Claude
Bourguignon est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement
nous sommes basés à Dijon et on
travaille si on va parler du travail on
travaille pour depuis 30 ans pour pour
aider les agriculteurs à respecter leur
sol
Claude donc moi pareil je suis ingénieur
agro j'ai fait une spécialité
microbiologie des sols je suis comme il
y avait qu'un seul laboche à
microbiologie des sols qui étaient à
Dijon j'ai rencontré Lydia nous sommes
mariés nous avons fondé notre famille et
fonder notre laboratoire d'analyses des
sols pour aider les agriculteurs
donc vous êtes des ingénieurs de terrain
vous regardez dans un microscope sur le
terrain ça fait 30 ans que vous faites
ça
on a décidé de vous venir de vous faire
venir aujourd'hui pour parler de la
santé des sols de la capacité des sols à
nourrir sa population qu'est-ce qui se
passe quand on met plus dans graines sur
des sols appauvri donc il est à son au
sol quels vont être les répercussions
quels sont nos répercussions déjà à
l'heure actuelle
Lydia les sols français quand on leur
met plus d'engrais est-ce qu'ils peuvent
quand même donner des choses
oui c'est une bonne question
heureusement heureusement que si on met
plus d'engrais les sols peuvent renaître
mais le problème c'est que on n'est pas
du tout les agriculteurs sont pas du
tout dans ce schéma puisqu'on leur dit
que sans engrais et bien on pourra pas
on pourra pas nourrir la planète les
sols ne produiront pas assez pour
nourrir tout le les milliards de
personnes sur terre alors que on peut on
peut le faire
Claude
c'est vrai que l'état des sols est
tellement mauvais que si on arrête
complètement les engrais on va tomber
sur des rendements faibles mais c'est le
on est obligé de passer par là si on
veut restaurer la vie des sols et c'est
un solvant il est parfaitement capable
si les sols étaient vivants on a détruit
un milliard de hectares de sol pendant
le 20e siècle si on n'avait pas détruit
ce milliards d'hectares mais on aurait
pas pour ce milliards c'est Ramadan le
professeur de d'écologie de l'université
l'ancienne université d'Orsay qu'on
appelle Nathan Paris 7 je crois et
on n'aurait pas perdu puisqu'on ne
cultive qu'un milliard 500 millions
d'hectares
si on n'est pas perdu ce milliards on
nourrirait tout le monde mais c'est la
destruction de nos sols qui nous posent
mettre dans une position très embêtante
est-ce que vous entendez vous deux sur
destruction des sols comment on a fait
pour les détruire c'est parce qu'on a
trop planté on a mis trop de choses
dedans c'est parce que ça veut dire quoi
destruction des sols
on a fait après le drame ça a été
l'après-guerre en fait puisque on a
voulu industrialiser l'agriculture
autrefois avant la guerre avant la
première guerre et après effectivement
ensuite après la deuxième guerre
mondiale en fait les agriculteurs
cultivaient leur sol comme on dit en bon
père de famille c'est-à-dire qui ils
étaient dans un équilibre agronomique la
forêt et les champs et avec
quand on est sorti de la guerre on a dit
pour la France les Français ont besoin
de il faut ont besoin de manger il faut
il faut nourrir nourrir et en fait
l'industrialisation est arrivée donc la
monoculture on a éclaté les zones
agricoles autrefois un agriculteur il
avait effectivement la forêt les animaux
la prairie il est il vivait en autarcie
et on a éclaté ce schéma là en dans les
bêtes au même endroit les céréales dans
un autre endroit la forêt dans un autre
endroit et en fait les soldes comme ils
avaient pu
le fumier de des animaux qu'ils avaient
pu la forêt pour restaurer ils se sont
détruits petit à petit en plus après on
est venu avec la monoculture donc plus
du tout cette biodiversité et les
industries la chimie est arrivée de
façon importante tout de suite après la
guerre nous on dit que en fait presque
le matériel de guerre a servi en fait à
hutte à travailler la terre les chars
sont arrivés les premiers tracteurs ce
sont des firmes américaines et qui
ressemblaient quand on va dans des dans
des musées agricoles on voit des
tracteurs qui ressemblent carrément à
des chars d'assaut les haies qui étaient
PC qui étaient tricoté et bien on est
passé au fil au fil de fer barbelé au
fil de fer barbelé et
et on s'est mis aussi on avait mot
démontré l'ybig avait montré que en fait
si on mettait de l'azote après phosphore
et potassium et surtout de l'azote on
allait augmenter les rendements et
l'azote pendant la guerre on l'a utilisé
pour faire des bons et donc ça a été et
bien le chemin tout de suite quoi et
c'est industrialisation a fait que
l'agriculteur il a perdu pour nous il a
perdu son bon sens en fait il écoute
plus sa terre il la regarde pas
la destruction d'un sol elle se fait en
trois étapes vous allez d'abord la
destruction biologique c'est-à-dire on
tue la vie du sol comment on fait pour
tuer les vues du sol on met des engrais
chimiques dans le sol les engrais
chimiques vont multiplier bactéries et
les bactéries minéralise à matière
organique elle brûle la matière
organique et les champignons vont
disparaître ces champions c'est eux qui
fabriquent la matière organique mais
comme il se multiplient 20 fois plus
lentement que les bactéries les
bactéries se multiplient elles éliminent
les champignons plus de fabrication du
musc comme il y a plus de matière
organique la faune qui s'en nourrit
disparaît et comme c'est la faune les
vers de terre qui passent leur temps à
remonter les éléments à la surface du
sol dans leurs excréments ce qu'on
appelle les turricules il remonte
l'azote la magnésie potassium etc puis
il faut les éléments descendent ils
descendent dans la nappe il descendent
dans les rivières et on accuse à 8h de
polluer parce que les sols se mettent à
perdre leurs éléments qui partent dans
les rivières et à ce moment-là vous
rentrez la dégradation chimique du sol
votre seule Persé réserve alimentaire et
une fois qu'il y a plus d'humus que vous
avez perdu les ions qui permettent
d'attacher ensemble les humus et les
argiles il y a les argiles étant plus
attachées elles partent ça s'appelle
l'érosion et dès qu'il se met à pleuvoir
les rivières sont pleines debout en fait
c'est la terre qui s'en va et elle part
à la mer et nous perdons nous perdons
chaque année
grosso modo en France on perde de
l'ordre d'un centimètre de terre par an
quoi
c'est c'est compliqué parce qu'on peut
pas sortir un chiffre comme ça parce
qu'il y a des sols tellement différents
que les niveaux d'érosion sont
évidemment pas les mêmes sur un immense
sur un argile localcaire sur mes grosso
modo c'est nous perdons de la terre
c'est que la terre à l'heure actuelle
par plus vite de se reconstitue donc ça
c'est très embêtant c'est quand vous
perdez votre patrimoine alimentaire on
voit ce qui se passe autour du bassin
méditerranéen qui était fertile et qui
maintenant est désertifié
les répercussions tout ça quand on a
plus de biodiversité dans le sol qu'il y
a plus cette symbiose entre la plante le
l'hygrométrie les vers de terre les
petites bêtes les petits champignons qui
permettent d'échanger entre la plante et
le sol on va dire entre le ciel et la
terre
les pertes de rendement quand on met pu
du dopping du dopage extérieur NPK des
mines de phosphore à gauche qu'est-ce
qui se passe combien de temps ça
pourrait mettre de reconstituer
correctement nos sols pour produire le
même rendement qu'avec l'industrie
agrochimique
alors moi je vais peut-être qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire le rendement c'est la
première la première question qu'on peut
se poser parce que si c'est faire un
rendement avec de l'azote du phosphore
et du potassium c'est à dire cette
fertilisation on va parler simplement
en fait quand on met de l'azote du
phosphore et du potassium on va créer en
fait on va modifier la le champ
électrique de la de la cellule de la
plante et en mettant ces entre autres
l'azote le nitrate on va faire rentrer
de l'eau on va créer la turgescence la
turgescence des légumes des pommes de
tout et en fait effectivement ça
augmente le rendement c'est comme vous
avez plus d'eau vous avez plus de poids
les légumes sont plus gros et on va dire
que mais on vend très cher l'eau
par rapport au plastique aussi
mais alors que et si on fait le produit
intrinsèque et quand on fait ça quand on
perturbe la cellule en fait il y a que
la potasse qui va rentrer et on va
provoquer des carences induites sur le
reste donc il y aura moins de calcium
moins de magnésium donc en fait le fruit
le légume est déjà moins riche en ces
éléments il est riche en eau et il est
moins riche dans ces éléments si on
revient c'est pour ça je dis qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire le rendement si c'est
pour faire des légumes qui sont beaux
grands mais qui de toute façon n'ont pas
quand on si on séchait complètement ils
ont pas autant de
valeur nutritive donc pour nous chaque
fois on nous met en avant oui mais je
vais perdre mon rendement mais est-ce
qu'on se nourrit de ces produits qui
sont gorgés d'eau on pourrait avoir
moins de volume moins de mais avoir des
choses beaucoup plus concentrées et
peut-être que ça équilibrerait les
choses
pour refaire un sol entre guillemets via
la question mais je pense que c'est il
faut que les agriculteurs le monde
agricole comprennent que le rendement
c'est pas la finalité de l'agriculture
voilà c'est pas de nourrir les gens
mais de les nourrir bien
Claude
la restauration d'un sol dépend de son
niveau de destruction si vous avez
simplement détruit sa vie la biologie
avec du compost on va pouvoir on va
pouvoir
en général nous on voit bon je dirais si
c'est derrière prairie c'est les seuls
les moins esquintés en 4-5 ans on
restaure la vie du sol bon si vous êtes
chez des betteraviers c'est un peu plus
long mais là ça peut monter entre 5 et
10 ans les soldes les plus esquintés les
seuls qui sont vraiment vraiment usés
les limons du du nord du bassin parisien
qui qui ont sont vraiment totalement
appauvris ils sont descendus au dessous
d'un pour cent de matière organique là
il faudra plutôt 15 à 20 ans donc ça va
dépendre si vous êtes comme c'est dans
le cas du limon du bassin parisien avec
des forts niveau d'érosion c'est c'est
comme si vous achetez une maison vous
achetez une maison si la toiture est
foutue il reste plus que les quatre murs
je savais que vous coûter beaucoup plus
cher à restaurer que s'il y a simplement
les peintures à refaire et la moquette
donc selon les c'est pour ça que quand
on va chez un état qu'on analyse le sol
on leur dit voilà vous êtes à ce
niveau-là de destruction sachez qu'il va
vous falloir tant de temps et évidemment
de l'investissement et là pour le moment
l'état il les aide pas à restaurer la
vie des sols donc c'est difficile pour
eux quand je vous entends
j'ai l'impression que les sols français
et peut-être les sols pas que les sols
français c'est ça ressemble à de
l'hydroponie d'extérieur c'est à dire
que vous avez des sols qui ont été
standardisés c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
presque plus rien dedans et ça ressemble
à l'hydroponie alors pour ceux qui ne
sont pas familiers avec ce genre de
terminaison c'est soit une plante qui
pousse dans un milieu totalement
artificiel hydraté avec une solution
standardisée
de la plante n'a pas ça et bien en fait
elle ne pousse pas il y a pas de
rendement et plus ça va plus on
fertilise parce que les soldes sont de
moins en moins vivants et c'est un
cercle infernal pour les agriculteurs et
pardon et effectivement ils disent mais
si je n'utilise pas ça je m'en sors pas
mais oui et on fait nous ça fait 30 ans
c'est une fuite en avant c'est à dire
qu'on dit oui mais
il y a un moment ça sera
presque de la roche il y aura plus rien
qui va pousser donc on diminue plus en
plus les rendements on est de plus en
plus nombreux sur terre
jusqu'où on va aller il y a un moment où
on sera
là la science et la technologie vont
nous sauver Lydia on va créer des
Frankenstein de la génétique avec une
semence qui va avoir des super racines
vous y croyez vous y croyez pas à ça du
tout moi je n'y crois pas pourquoi
parce que je la génétique j'y crois pas
parce que je pense que la nature
parce que on a on a fait des hybrides
avec des énormes rendements en ce moment
on veut faire aussi des dans le vin
puisqu'on travaille beaucoup des des
plans qui sont résistants par exemple à
la maladie comme ça il y aura plus rien
et quand on travaille avec ces séminons
ils disent pendant de deux ans trois ans
j'ai rien mais au bout de quatre ans
tiens j'ai une petite tâche puis cinq
ans j'ai deux tâches puis 6 ans j'ai dit
tâches et en fait petit à petit la
nature va reprendre ses droits
ou alors effectivement il faut
travailler avec hors sol complètement
sur de la vermiculite et puis on met les
doses mais ça n'a pas le même goût je
pense que quand même l'alimentation il y
a pas que se nourrir il y a le plaisir
de connaître des goûts différents et
malgré tout cette nourriture là nous on
en est persuadé ça n'a pas la qualité
pas que du goût et de la qualité
l'énergie et le potentiel de de ces
légumes de ces céréales
de toute façon il y a une chose qui est
absolument fondamentale se dire avec
l'agitif je vais faire plonger les
racines complètement faux pour qu'une
racine plonge il faut qu'elle ait de
l'oxygène et qu'elle est pas tout de
suite je suis pas génial
et de l'eau parce que c'est un organe
qui respire la racine or si vous traitez
votre solde glyphosate il y a plus de
faune le sol se referme pour vous donner
une idée une porosité d'aliments
c'est plus une marque attention
si vous voulez le silo si l'eau et
l'oxygène ne rentre pas qu'est-ce qui va
se passer la racine va rester en surface
nous on fait les profils constamment et
on voit par exemple dans les vignes qui
sont traitées au désherbant les racines
ne sont sur 30 cm quand on est sur des
vignes qui sont traitées en biologie en
biodynamie on a de la racine qui plonge
parce qu'elle a de l'oxygène
et il faut savoir aussi une chose
fondamentale c'est que si votre sol est
fermé Laurent pas dedans ça fera
d'érosion et ça va inonder partout et le
l'eau et d'autres apportent d'autant
plus d'oxygène qu'elle est froide c'est
donc en hiver qu'on va mettre de
l'oxygène dans les sols donc si en hiver
votre sol est fermé parce que vous allez
vous l'avez vous n'êtes pas entretenu la
vie c'est au riche en oxygène pour pas
rentrer partira dans la rivière et votre
sol il va se fixer et vos racines vont
remonter remonter remonter et là vous
pouvez faire toute la génétique du monde
si vous racine export 30 cm au lieu
d'explorer un mètre 50 les plantes sont
pas nourris de la même façon donc il
faudra rajouter du coco il faudra
remettre des engrais chimiques faudra
faudra compléter ce que le sol ne peut
plus donner
entendu le mieux le mot biodynamie
c'est un mot qui fait référence à quoi
est-ce que c'est une nouvelle religion
est-ce que c'est une valeur technique
scientifique qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
biodynamique en valeur scientifique je
pense qu'il faut enlever ce moule là
puisqu'en fait il y a aucune étude pas
nous on a travaillé sur des vignes en
biodynamie mais en fait il y a aucune
étude sérieuse faite par
mais il y a aucune étude sérieuse pour
pour
dire effectivement qu'il y a une
différence réelle scientifique puisqu'à
l'heure actuelle quand même dans
beaucoup de cas si on ne prouve pas
quelque chose scientifiquement et bien
on fait personne n'y croit mais oui il
faut
tout à fait c'est normal on écarte
mais donc il y a effectivement
la biodynamie c'est c'est par rapport
aux astres c'est par rapport à
des gens regardent
la lune en lune montante en l'une
descendante ce qui était c'est pas
démontré mais c'était un savoir paysan
paysan mettait leur radis ou leurs
plantes quand ils voulaient que ce soit
de des plantes de racines et bien ils le
mettait en l'une descendant il y a il y
a une perception paysanne qui c'est le
temps qui leur a montré que ça marchait
alors comment le démontrer ça c'est
autre chose mais c'est vrai qu'il y a
énormément on en parle beaucoup c'est la
c'est quelque chose qui est dans la
mouvance puisque en fait on utilise plus
de produits de traitement on va
travailler avec des plantes donc c'est
dans la mouvance
la mouvance de quoi de la biologie de la
de plus utiliser de produits très de
produits de traitement de plus utiliser
de pesticides depuis utilisé
on travaille avec les plantes
vous lisez Steiner vous dites le gars il
filmait c'est lui qui a fondé la
vitamine
quand vous lisez Steiner vous avez
l'impression qu'il fumait la moquette le
gars parce qu'il vous dit il faut
prendre de la gousse de vache la mettre
dans une corne l'enterrer
à la Saint Michel Jean c'est très
choquant alors
ce qui est intéressant dans l'approche
du monde vivant c'est que il y a des
dimensions dans le monde vivant que la
science pour le moment est incapable
d'aborder c'est en particulier le niveau
de l'énergie l'énergie du monde vivante
ça se calcule pas c'est à dire que
si vous mesurez vous analysez le sang
d'une personne une seconde avant sa mort
et une seconde après sa mort vous verrez
pas de différence dans l'analyse de sang
et pourtant il y a une énorme différence
il est mort il suivant c'est quand même
une différence gigantesque et ça la
science elle sait pas encore le faire
elle attend la décomposition des tissus
pour pouvoir dire qu'effectivement
d'ailleurs il y a plein de problèmes
dans les hôpitaux de savoir est-ce qu'on
débranche la personne ou pas est-ce
qu'il est mort on est très mal à l'aise
vis-à-vis de ça Steiner a une approche
strictement cette un élève de Gueux une
approche qui est strictement poétique et
strictement qui n'a rien à voir avec le
rationnel qui est quelque chose de
secteur
plutôt non je pense que c'est les
suiveurs de Steiner sont devenus secteur
lui il a il a donné il a balancé des
choses des choses comme ça des
fulgurances comme font les poètes les
poètes
aussi des horreurs mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ce qu'on peut
faire nous la seule chose qu'on fait
nous c'est qu'on mesure l'activité
biologique des sols en biodynamie ou en
biologie en conventionnelle ou et l'INRA
confirmer nos travaux c'est
qu'effectivement c'est dans les soldes
cultivés qui a plus d'activités
biologiques comment ça marche on est
incapable de vous dire comment ça marche
mais il se passe quelque chose et on a
fait des dégustations en aveugle avec
des vignerons
activité biologique est-ce qu'on a plus
d'activités biologiques et ce qu'on a
plus de faune au niveau de la de la
concentration des éléments assimilables
par la plante et ce qu'on en a moins ou
plus en maillot dynamique en profondeur
et là on pourrait dire oui c'est il se
passe quelque chose où il se passe rien
mais pour l'instant c'est pour ça que la
biodynamie il y a des gens qui peut qui
mettent des choses que effectivement
c'est des gens qui sont complètement
dans le rêve mais les gens qui font de
la biodynamie pure et qu'il appliquent
jusqu'au bout et en fait eux pour eux
leur vin changer les légumes ont changé
mais c'est pas c'est pour ça je disais
ce n'est pas mesuré à l'heure actuelle
scientifiquement et tant que ça sera pas
fait on mettra des étiquettes sur la
biodynamie nous dans notre laboratoire
parce que je voulais dire ça nous on y
croit parce qu'on a vu des choses
mais elles ne sont pas c'est très
difficile
on constate les analyses qu'on a fait
dans un domaine en Bourgogne ou en fait
on a travaillé chez un vieil rond en
Bourgogne le domaine le fleuve on peut
le nommer et en fait cette personne non
qui était une
qui croyait qui qui croyait en la
biodynamie et qui voulait que son
personnel et cette comprendre pourquoi
c'était différent donc elle nous a donné
deux parcelles à travailler elle en a
gardé une en biologie et une en
biodynamie on a mesuré les activités
biologiques
en surface en profondeur on a mesuré les
éléments assimilables en surface en
profondeur
oligo-éléments et éléments et on a vu
une différence
significative surtout en profondeur les
racines étaient plus profondes aussi
donc ça c'est des résultats mais on a on
en a fait un autre chez une chez un on
l'a fait surtout sur la vigne chez une
vigneronne en Suisse voilà mais c'est
pour ça je lui faudrait que des des
organismes scientifiques qui ne font que
de la recherche que du travail
scientifique se pose des questions
là-dessus
revenons revenons à la standardisation
des sols la standardisation des semences
qu'est-ce qui se passe il y a un
catalogue de semences ils sont tous
brevetés pas breveté est-ce que
normalement
je suis désolé mais je reprends vous
arguments la fraise de de Bretagne la
pomme de telle région c'était des
semences qui étaient adapté à au terroir
au sol
par la loi de Mendel si l'agriculteur
reproduit cette graine qui vient de deux
individus malingres et ben il y aura la
moitié de la des individus qui vont
naître de ça qui seront malades qui se
viendront du parent a et du parent B et
seulement 50% qui fera du bon rendement
donc agriculteur va perdre de l'argent
donc il est il est comme ça avec le
smancy il est obligé de lui racheter les
graines tous les ans ils ont ils ont eu
cette idée extrêmement intelligente de
rendre le marché captif et ensuite ils
ont fait un catalogue c'est comme si
vous aviez un catalogue de voiture et on
vous dit cette voiture vous avez pas le
droit de l'acheter cela vous pouvez pas
vous ne pouvez acheter que ces voitures
là totalement
Claude tout cet argent il faut qu'il y
ait un retour notre recherche nous la
boue c'est un peu normal non
mais on n'est pas obligé de rendre les
grains de stériles on peut pratiquer la
sélection massacre comme on pratiquait
tous les agriculteurs depuis 7000 ans
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait les
agriculteurs ils ont toujours cueilli
les meilleurs les meilleurs épis qui
gardaient pour la reproduction et les
autres étaient transformés en farine
dans les animaux ils prenaient toujours
dans une descendance les plus beaux
individus et il les reproduisait ils ont
fait de la sélection Massa mais pendant
cette nuit là
et en fait il y a eu un choix aussi dans
ce qui a été sélectionné c'est c'est
reconnu c'est souvent dans les blés ils
vont utiliser ces des plantes si elles
n'ont pas le le bagage de fertilisation
qui va avec donc en fait c'est semencier
ces gros industries ils ont le monopole
de la semence ils ont
ils vendent de la fertilisation et
souvent comme on fertilise trop et ça ça
induit parce que quand on fertilise
beaucoup les plantes sont quand même
plus souvent malades donc c'est eux
aussi qui vendent les produits pour les
soigner et ben je vais vous dire on
n'est pas obligé d'acheter chez eux mais
c'est obligé pourquoi parce qu'un
agriculteur ne peut pas alors il y a eu
une évolution mais n'a pas le droit vous
ne pouvez pas et c'est pour ça qu'il y a
une profession par exemple qui est née
c'est les les céréaliers boulanger
parce que en fait quand ils avaient des
semences anciennes de blé il pouvait
vous n'avez pas le droit de le porter
celui qui boit la graine pour faire la
farine ne peut pas prendre parce
qu'elles ne sont pas brevetées dans le
catalogue du Nice donc c'est ces
agriculteurs on dit et bien on va
devenir boulanger et donc ils ont le
droit de faire leur farine et après de
faire le pain et c'est pour ça qu'on l'a
vu et des pins qui sont faits avec
une par exemple de l'amidonie ou le
petit épeautre ou le grand épeautre
alors qu'avant il y a une dizaine
d'années c'est très très compliqué parce
qu'en fait ils ont détourné le catalogue
de Venice
alors pour vous donner une idée il y
avait il y a 10 espèces de blé en Europe
et il y avait plus de 10000 variétés au
19e à travers l'Europe et on a comme dit
Lydia on a sélectionné dans les espèces
celles ne répondait pas aux engrais par
exemple les poutres il répond très mal
aux engrais on l'éliminer et on a gardé
finalement deux blés un blé le blé dur
un Triticum du rhum et trity comme cet
hiver parce que cela il répondait très
bien et on a éliminé tous les autres et
ensuite on a sélectionné ça dans les
sonneries riches donc les gens qui sont
sur les seuls pauvres s'ils mettent pas
d'engrais ils sont cuits quoi alors
qu'on aurait pu faire une sélection
totalement différente on aurait pu faire
une sélection en champ sélection Massal
dans des sols différents repérez les
espèces les plus rustiques et les mieux
adaptés au sol pauvres pour ne pas avoir
besoin d'utiliser les engrais et là là
les paysans eux ils en auraient
énormément bénéficié et alors que là on
les a coincé qui sont je sais pas pour
rien s'il y en a un qui suscitent tous
les deux jours vous êtes en contact avec
eux souvent
comment il se sentent nos agriculteurs
alors ils certes il y en a beaucoup qui
suit ici ils gagnent pas un radis
ils sont épuisés des fouets sont malades
avec les substances qui qui dans le
barbotage ils sont endettés
avant c'était pas comme ça les
agriculteurs c'était les rois du monde
oui c'était les rois du monde mais il y
en a plus beaucoup quand même on a perdu
95% de nos agriculteurs donc il y a
aussi il va y avoir un vrai problème et
c'est une profession la plus âgée
c'est la plus âgée des jeunes ne veulent
pas reprendre quand vous gagnez pas le
SMIC quand vous êtes endetté quand ça va
pas c'est pas une profession qu'on a
valorisé et ils sont pas bien et quand
ils font appel à nous en général c'est
qu'ils sont vraiment
voilà ils sont au dernier rouleau ils
sont à la fin en disant j'ai tout essayé
mais ça marche pas et donc là on a dit
on va regarder le sol quoi
et là on essaie de les aider mais
souvent c'est des gens qui ou alors qui
veulent vraiment changer mais en réalité
culture c'est vraiment des agriculteurs
qui sont au bout du rouleau quoi
regardez le sol ça me fait penser genre
un dermato qui dit on va regarder ce qui
se passe sur ta peau regardez le sol ça
veut dire quoi on fait un trou on voit
ce qui se passe on prend le microscope
on voit ce qui se passe ça peut être
combien de centimètres combien de
centimètres combien de mètres
quand vous montrez ça aux agriculteurs
ils comprennent tout de suite oui ils
comprennent mais d'ailleurs quand on a
commencé on demandait au début c'était
Claude qui faisait le profil pour qu'on
lissait pour rentrer dedans et c'était
drôle parce que l'agriculteur il était
au-dessus comme ça puis disait bah c'est
la première fois que je vois un
ingénieur qui est à mes pieds ce que lui
il était au-dessus et puis nous on était
dans la ça leur fait du bien un petit
peu les ingénieurs de se retrouver les
mains à terre et ça ça les surprenait et
en fait il y en a il y en a une qui nous
disaient on n'a jamais vu une autre sol
comme ça en fait pour eux c'était une
vraie découverte quoi comment la racine
descendait alors effectivement on fait
un profil on essaie de rentrer dans le
profil et on va regarder tous les
horizons en fait il y avait quelqu'un il
y a très longtemps et moi j'aime
beaucoup sans orgueil les gens nous ont
dit vous ne vous comportez comme un
médecin du sol parce qu'en fait on fait
un diagnostic on le regarde on le sent
on l'écoute et parce qu'à un seul qui
sent bon tout de suite on est content
parce qu'on se dit on va vous entendez
on écoute le seul parce que là ça fait
penser à ceux qui font des bisous aux
arbres voilà non parce que quand vous
avez
quand on peut quand vous avez de la
faune la faune en se déplaçant et bien
en fait il faut que ça soit mais par
exemple de les fourmis ou les carottes
sur le le sol à la surface si vous vous
taisez vous les entendez c'est pas c'est
vous êtes dans les métiers de
le moindre petit son vous allez
l'entendre le sentir il y a des sols qui
sentent très bon il y a des sols qui
sentent vraiment pas bons la couleur
donc en fait on fait marcher non
innocence comment il est dur quand on
marche et ça on dit la première chose
qu'on dit à l'agriculteur on va faire on
va travailler nos sens on va marcher
comment vous le ressentez après on va
vous allez le sentir vous allez le
toucher vous allez après on regarde les
racines est-ce qu'elle descendent est-ce
qu'elles sont en forme de comme ça en
angle droit là à quelle profondeur elles
sont est-ce qu'elles sont blanches
est-ce qu'elles sont rondes est-ce
qu'elles sont athléties et après on a on
a même des tests de terrain pour voir
s'il respire le sol s'y respire pas les
échanges gazeux entre le sol la plante
il faut être très précis en termes de
termes parce que là aussi si on vous
entend il faut écouter le sol il respire
il faut expliquer ce mécanisme là on n'a
pas en mesure pas avec un micro ça c'est
sûrs qui font du bruit et ça on l'entend
très bien par exemple le test du
calcaire on met de l'acide ça se met à
bouillonner ou s'il y a pas de caca ça
bouillonne pas du tout donc on le met
entre l'oreille pour savoir ça
bouillonne un peu donc là on l'écoute
quelque part on écoute notre test de
terrain et ça à la suite de ce
diagnostic de terrain qu'on va prendre
des échantillons à différentes
profondeur qui eux seront analysés au
laboratoire sur le plan physique
chimique et biologique et par exemple la
couleur on a on a un livre qui s'appelle
le münsol et qui est un livre que tous
les les gens qui étudient le sol dans le
monde vous avez c'est une planche qui
met la la concentration du de la couleur
si on est dans les rouges c'est alors
c'est rouge ça va être r si c'est jaune
c'est y si c'est bleu c'est g donc il y
a un code et avec des chiffres et si
vous le sol et en 10 y r par exemple 4 6
vous dites ça à quelqu'un qui étudie le
sol il sait exactement quelle couleur à
ce sol c'est vraiment comme un fantôme
et donc nous on travaille avec ça sur le
sol on identifie la couleur et quand on
revient quelques années après ou et que
le sol a évolué on avait le point de
démarrage et on va aller regarder quand
le sol est jaune c'est un sol qui
respire pas trop bien et si on voit le
rouge donc
une planche avec la couleur rouge on va
dire votre sol est en train de
s'oxygéner vous avez plus d'oxygène
votre fer au lieu d'être sous la forme
ferreuse et fait de plus vient en
féérique et la couleur le fer le faire
ferrique c'est la rouille et le sol
devient rouge donc ça c'est c'est
oui c'est quantifié
on a décidé aussi de vous faire venir
parce qu'on a inquiet par rapport à la
sécurité alimentaire d'Europe on est
inquiet aussi parce que comme vous avez
pu remarquer il y a une immense guerre à
notre porte dans un pays producteur de
céréales par un pays producteur
d'engrais et donc on est relativement
inquiet par rapport à l'Europe parce que
quand on vous écoute ou quand on se
balade dans les champs on se rend bien
compte que il y a un quoi quand même
quand vous baladez dans un champ et que
le champ est Hannut et que vous
ressortez avec vos bottes avec 50 cm de
plus en dessous de vous et forcément un
problème si c'est assez c'est pas normal
de repartir avec 50 cm debout sous ses
bottes donc la question qui me
m'inquiète c'est
si on a plus d'engrais ou si on a des
engrais qui coûtent un bras les
agriculteurs vont arrêter de mettre de
l'engrais donc les rendements vont
baisser donc je repose ma question il
faut combien de temps pour régénérer un
sol
tous les soldes ne sont pas comparables
comme vous venez de nous dire mais le
trou d'air de production alimentaire
vous l'évaluez à combien d'années si ça
devient tendu
nous on a une référence les premiers
agriculteurs à qui on a appris à ne plus
labourer donc déjà ralentir la
destruction du sol stocker la matière
organique en surface on arrive à faire
monter le taux de matière organique
selon les sols entre 0,1 et 0,3% par an
ce qui est pas mal donc les plus anciens
ça fait 20 ans qu'on travaille avec eux
ces gens qui sont passés de
1,2,3 mètres organiques à plus de 3%. et
c'est des gens qui du coup ne mettent
plus de potasses baissé par de l'azote
le mettre plus de phosphore tu es ils
sont en train ils ont démarré avant
d'arriver à la catastrophe dans laquelle
on est maintenant parce qu'ils ont
compris plutôt que les autres qu'il
fallait arrêter de détruire leur
patrimoine et là on voit eux je me fais
pas de souci pour eux si on leur retire
les engrais parce que ils produiront
mais ce qu'on a toujours pas compris là
là on va on va être mal c'est ça va être
plutôt nous la Banque mondiale nous a
demandé de faire une étude sur la Free
l'Amérique du Sud une zone demandée
d'évaluer combien ça coûterait de
restaurer les soldes détruits par la
culture du soja et tout c'est des sommes
qui varient entre selon les sols entre
3000 et 5000 dollars à l'hectare il y a
300 millions d'hectares de détruits donc
vous calculez 300 millions que
multiplient entre 3 et 5000 dollars ça
fait beaucoup d'argent quand vous
décapitalisez dans un patrimoine quand
il faut remettre de l'argent il va
falloir que l'humanité mettre de
l'argent dans ses sols et ça en pleine
crise avec de l'inflation et tout on
n'est pas bien oui une vraie inquiétude
nous on est il y a une vraie inquiétude
je pense que si on continue il va
falloir qu'on qu'on reprenne qu'on
reprenne les sols il faut que il y ait
un vrai travail une aide un vrai travail
chez l'agriculteur de dire il faut que
il faut que je travaille avec mon sol
quand vous discutez parce que ça c'est
gratuit le sol il est gratuit quelque
part
on a de moins on a un réchauffement de
la planète on a de moins en moins de
pluie mais si on a un sol qui est en bon
état le peu de pluie que l'on a elle va
rentrer donc en fait on va stocker en
plus Claude disait quand on remet la vie
on capte du carbone puisque si vous
augmentez votre matière organique de 0,3
de 0,1 dans le cas moyen puis 03 en fait
cette matière organique c'est du carbone
vous dégagez nettement moins de CO2 donc
le problème du réchauffement de la
planète serait diminué il faut expliquer
en détail
la production de CO2 avec l'agriculture
quand on balance des engrais
ça fait quoi ça a tendance à se balader
c'est
l'élément chimiques comme ça et du coup
vous évaporez vous allez faire partir de
la matière organique qui va partir sous
forme de gaz carbonique et donc
l'agriculture participe à peu près 30%
de la production de gaz carbonique c'est
quoi vos chiffres ça vient d'où ça
allait 30%
alors j'ai pu lui il y a plein de
diversité qui bossent alors actuelle sur
les sur le un labour les estimations qui
sont faites aussi bien en Europe qu'aux
États-Unis à la Bourse et une tonne de
gaz carbonique qui part à celui direct
sous couvert c'était vous arrêtez de
labourer et vous semez en découvert ça
stocke entre 3 et 5 tonnes vous voyez le
bilan est complètement différent on a
calculé réalisation américaine en ce
moment qui disent que si tous les
acteurs arrêtaient delaborés passés
aussi direct on baisserait de 40% de
dégagement de gaz carbonique
le réchauffement climatique on va parler
de la France et puis de l'Europe vous
pensez que notre cheptel de plantes
super productrice elle va se comporter
comment il va se comporter comment notre
cheptel de plantes il va résister au
réchauffement climatique notre
ingénierie végétal va réussir à nous
faire des variétés résistantes
au sécheresse résistante à tout ça vous
y croyez pas du tout et vous misez plus
sur les les semences paysannes
sélectionnés avec des gars qui font
gaffe depuis très longtemps où vous
pensez que le stress hydrique sur nos
plantes ça va être très problématique ou
pas
le stress hydrique sur nos plantes ça va
être très problématique si en fait on ne
fait pas quelque chose sur les sols
parce que quand vous dites peut-être si
variétés mais les variétés anciennes
faut quand même se dire bon on parle de
réchauffement de la planète mais des
épisodes de froid de chaleur il y en a
eu quand même d'autres les plantes c'est
les céréales anciennes enfin les graines
anciennes elles ont subi elles ont elles
ont
elles ont la mémoire de ce qui s'est
passé tout ce qui est en hybride c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué mais la mémoire
il faut utiliser un autre terme
peut-être
les plantes ont deux fois plus de gènes
que nous ce qui a été le scandale pour
les généticiens ils pensaient que
l'espèce qui avait le gène est plus
complexe était les hommes on est
tellement brillant tellement puis on a
deux fois moins de gène que la voix
or et donc ils ont appelé ça c'est cette
double ADN et généticien après ça John
kadhane ils ont dit c'est l'ADN de merde
comme si des plantes depuis des millions
d'années trans se transmettaient la
molécule la plus coûteuse en énergie qui
est l'ADN qui est le stockage génétique
évident qu'il faut arrêter de prendre la
vie pour être complètement débile si ça
consomme beaucoup d'énergie c'est qu'il
y a une raison et notre hypothèse à nous
c'est que en fait ce double ce double
bagage génétique c'est de la mémoire la
mémoire climatique c'est-à-dire que la
plante est capable de s'adapter si vous
lui donnez possibilité de s'enraciner
profondément d'être sur un seul livre
elle va être capable de mettre en
mouvement des ADN dormant qui sont en
dormance pour le moment et pour être
capable de s'exprimer
c'est notre hypothèse
expliqué ce que moi je pense je pense
mais
pour on revient alors effectivement nous
c'est peut-être depuis 30 ans notre
notre compte enfin oui notre combat
notre travail c'est de dire que si on ne
travaille pas sur le sol
c'est-à-dire lui redonner cette porosité
le fait que l'eau pénètre c'est pas
normal que
quand on a la
pluie un peu un peu importante qu'on
entend sans arrêt dans les médias et que
les rivières sont complètement colorées
il y a des glissements de terrain mais
parce que le sol n'a pu n'a plus de
structure comme il a plus de matière
organique et que les argiles étant très
très fragiles et bien en fait ça part et
personne n'en parle tout le monde dit
c'est à cause de la pluie c'est à cause
du réchauffement de la planète mais il
faut quand même se poser la question
pourquoi on en est arrivé là pourquoi
les riv sont complètement chocolat c'est
parce que en fait le sol n'est pas
capable de de faire rentrer l'eau et
d'avoir la structure quand vous avez
quand on a un sol qui est plus riche en
matière organique la matière organique
est capable de capter beaucoup plus ces
communes le la matière organique donc
vous avez des sols qui se gonflent
beaucoup plus en eau à une réserve d'eau
qu'un seul qui va se retrouver avec
moins ou moins 1% de matière organique
qui n'aura pas cette capacité là donc en
fait c'est un stockage d'eau de
d'oxygène parce que un seul qui est
compacté et bien en fait il ne peut pas
il n'est pas comme une époque donc il ne
capte pas l'oxygène quand on n'a pas
d'eau un sol sec et sans oxygène et
racines descendent pas elles ont besoin
de ça donc en fait il y a un côté de bon
sens dans retourner à une agriculture
qui qui est durable mais ça voudra il
faudra remettre on ne parle pas assez va
falloir remettre des arbres les arbres
sont des des précurus enfin sont
extrêmement importants c'est eux qui
ramènent avec la photosynthèse de
l'oxygène c'est eux qui permettent à
l'eau grâce à le racine de d'enrichir
les nappes phréatiques quand on est
quand il y a le dos et puis surtout ben
le quand on a les feuilles les bras
c'est eux et c'est là-dessus qu'on vit
c'est eux qui ramène la matière
organique et on a complètement des
forestiers on n'arrête pas de déforester
donc en fait c'est un vrai retour c'est
revenir alors effectivement c'est
peut-être un côté de dire ouais c'était
les anciens mais les anciens ils avaient
pas tous ces produits il fallait
vraiment qu'ils s'en sortent et ils
avaient une agriculture qui était qui
était plus oui agro silvo pastoral
est-ce que vous motorisez est un peu
turbulent avec vous
on est sur une économie et une
consommation énergétique qui est
pratiquement sur une fonction
exponentielle on a fait une révolution
verte ce qu'ils appellerait révolution
verte c'était en quelle année Claude
donc la révolution verte ça démarre ça
démarre au début des années 70 on
mélange à la fois la sélection génétique
les apports d'engrais les apports de
pesticides donc ce qui a permis aussi à
notre population de croître parce que on
avait accès à de la bouffe pas cher ça
entre guillemets augmenté le pouvoir
d'achat pratiquement au détriment des
agriculteurs mais mais est-ce que vous
pensez qu'on peut revenir avec une
agriculture traditionnelle
traditionnelle
sur cette fonction exponentielle de
consommation ou est-ce qu'il y a quelque
chose à travailler côté agriculture ou
côté population je m'exprime peut-être
pas assez précisément est-ce que
l'agriculture traditionnaliste ou
traditionnelle telle que vous l'exposez
peut nourrir une société qui est sur une
fonction exponentielle de
alors j'aimerais que vous me parliez des
il faut plus dire le mot agriculture
nous faisons plus de l'agriculture nous
faisons de la petroculture c'est à dire
que notre production d'aliments est
basée sur la consommation du pétrole en
moyenne pour la série culture on est à
10 calories de pétrole pour faire une
calorie alimentaire de céréales et en
hors sol pour une tomate Orsol c'est 36
calories de pétrole pour faire une
calorie de tomate un système absurde
normalement
l'agriculture c'est l'utilisation de
l'énergie solaire qui elle normalement
doit durer 4 milliards d'années donc on
a on a quoi faire devant nous mais là on
a complètement inversé le processus
c'est plus du tout une agriculture
utilisatrice de mes énergétique l'idée
consomme beaucoup les tracteurs
consomment beaucoup d'essence les tout
tout coûte cher tout coûte cher parce
que les blés les blés qui sont remplis
d'eau faut les faire sécher dans des
silos les maïs faut les faire sécher
dans des cils comme vous faites sécher
une céréales beaucoup de propriétés on
peut plus faire un corn flakes avec un
maïs qui est qui a été séché dans un
silo et c'est pour sécher c'est encore
énergie c'est encore du pétrole possible
il faut lui retirer l'eau qu'on lui a
fait rentrer par les engrais donc voyons
dans un système où l'énergie est devenue
un facteur central c'est pour ça qu'il
s'en sortent plus agriculteurs ils
dépensent trop d'énergie pour se nourrir
vous êtes au courant de la notion de pic
énergétique depuis
la déplétion normalement on dit que
c'était en 2006 c'est ce qu'on a en tant
que selon les gisements
mais moi
dans votre question je pense que Claude
pour moi en partie raison mais je pense
qu'il va falloir que
et ça ça va être compliqué surtout avec
les pays émergents il va falloir qu'on
change notre mode de se nourrir à
l'heure actuelle autrefois on mangeait
on parlait la poule au pot du dimanche
je veux dire quand des gens mangent de
la viande le midi le soir 7 jours sur 7
effectivement les la viande en plus mise
c'est à dire en camp concentrationnaire
ça pose énormément de problèmes on les
accuse d'ailleurs de polluer puisque
quand elles sont en état de dégagent
beaucoup plus de méthane puisqu'on leur
donne du on leur donne des de
l'alimentation qui est fermentée et ça
leur fait effectivement des dégagements
de métal donc on dit qu'une vache pollue
pollue parce que quand elle pète mais
quand mais elle pète quand elle est en
stabulation quand elle est au champ elle
pète pas du du méthane mais il va
falloir sur le pet de la vache
je vous expliquez
une vache c'est un ruminant normalement
donc c'est une mangeuse d'herbe en fait
elle mange pas l'air vraiment je les
microbes qui dansent intestin vont
décomposer l'herbe et ben ensuite manger
ces microbes donc elle a deux des
estomacs qui permettent la fermentation
donc une vache comment elle fait pour
mieux ses microbes et le cette école va
sortir une boulette d'herbe elle va
faire 64 coups de rumination puis elle
va avaler plus vous limitez d'azote dans
l'alimentation puis vous mettez du soja
plus vous limitez de la viande et tout
moins le rumine puisqu'elle nourrit très
bien ses micros comme elle le rumine
plus elle rentre ça rentre en aérobiose
et elle se met dégager du métal au lieu
c'est pas les vaches alerte qui dégagent
l'élevage industriel qui dégage les
méthane c'est ça et ça on se garde bien
le préciser voyez on dirait les vaches
elles pètent non les vaches
industrielles pètent pas les vaches à
l'herbe pas les cochons qui sont dehors
c'est lui qui pollue l'élevage
industriels polluent par les méthane
mais bon je rien je pense que il faudra
parce que quand les met à l'herbe qu'on
les
l'animal consomme demande plus d'énergie
que une céréale ou qu'une légumineuse on
pourrait remplacer les protéines de par
des légumineuses moi je suis d'origine
italienne je veux dire l'Italie
déjà bien émergé là quand même mais la
qualité pour vous recevoir et la qualité
d'un chinois c'est de manger de la
viande et il en mange énormément quand
il peut bon ils sont un certain nombre
quand même donc en fait c'était des gens
qui se nourissaient avec du bois plus de
céréales donc il faudra qu'on change le
mode de nourriture de du monde pour
permettre une économie parce que je ne
crois pas moi si on continue à consommer
tel qu'on consomme que la planète qui
est qui est finie elle va pas elle va
pas grandir et qu'on puisse nourrir
autant il va falloir qu'on chambre on
change notre mode de vie
vous créez ce que disait Lydia
l'équilibre a grossi le veau pastorale
c'était vous êtes obligé de faire des
pour empêcher les bêtes de sauver parce
que c'est ça au début il est comme
disait l'idéal ils étaient PC on est
très sec pour que les bêtes puissent pas
passer à travers la donc vous aviez des
arbres en plus dans la hay il y avait
des paires roues il y avait tout il vous
voyez que les gibiers l'accueillette
champignon etc était un complément
alimentaire très important jusqu'à la
gare de 14 pour la population paysanne
parce que ça apportait des tas de
d'états de ligo-éléments et puis la bête
quand elle est à l'herbe on lui fait une
peinture et la peinture la gardait en
général 4,50 le taux de matière
organique montée ensuite on détruisait
la peinture on faisait une céréale et on
faisait plusieurs céréales des
légumineuses donc il y avait une
rotation donc on maintenait les après la
guerre on était à 4% de matière
organique dans l'agriculture européenne
maintenant on est à moins de moins de 2
on a perdu plus de la moitié de notre
matière organique parce qu'on a retiré
quand une bête est dans un état élevage
industriel elle se nourrit de soja qui
arrive du Brésil alors il est déjà le
bilan CO2 quand ça débarque du Brésil ou
d'Argentine cette bête ne voit jamais
d'herbe donc il y a plus de prairies
donc les gars qu'est-ce qu'il faut à la
place de prairie du maïs le maïs et de
l'eau c'est de l'engrais chimique c'est
du pesticides et ça ça détruit encore la
matière organique donc vous rentrez dans
un cercle infernal ou sans et vous avez
de moins en moins de matière organique
parce que les bêtes au lieu de brouter
malbroue plus il y a plus de prairie
vous aimez parler du système Maya
pourquoi
système agricole maille trois graines
dans un trou le maïs qui monte le
haricot
pas
effectivement mais on est
là on est vraiment dans la rotation et
dans la biodiversité parce qu'en fait il
mettait la courge le maïs et le haricot
le maïs servait de tuteur ou haricots et
la courge était protégée parce que ça
fait des feuilles énormes donc on était
en couverture de sol le sol était
toujours couvert et ça fonctionne quand
dans la petite paysannerie mexicaine ou
même en Amérique du Sud en fait ils en
font les petits agriculteurs font ça
parce qu'en fait il y a aussi une
symbiose et en biodiversité on a
beaucoup moins de maladies parce que
effectivement on rompt par rapport à une
monoculture quand vous avez un champ
quand il y a il y a un
c'est pour tout mais ce n'est pas
industrialisable c'est impossible la
courge elle mûrit à un certain moment le
maïs a un autre moment et le haricot à
un autre moment donc c'est une
agriculture paysanne qui demande de la
main d'oeuvre il va falloir remettre les
gens
moi je dis que à l'heure actuelle on se
plaint beaucoup on dit qu'il y a moins
de chômeurs mais je trouve que si on
veut une agriculture durable et qui
permettent de faire de remettre ces
choses un peu en biodiversité il faudra
qu'on remette des paysans on peut pas on
peut pas on dit je dirais on peut pas
tout avoir le beurre la crémière sans y
mettre quelque chose et pour faire une
agriculture qui permet de remettre ces
sols en bon état il faudra que on remet
des mains c'est pas les machines c'est
pas les robots et à l'heure actuelle je
vois en vigne il y a des vignerons qui
n'en veulent plus qui veulent plus de
main d'oeuvre donc il y a un robot qui
élabore il y a un robot qui taille il y
a un robot qui ramasse il y a un robot
qui qui
trie les grains bientôt il y a un robot
qui goûtera et on vous fera du vin il y
a la main la main de l'homme la main de
se toucher de savoir à quel moment je on
en met plus et les robots sont en train
de gagner tous mes énormes dans
énormément en agriculture et les
agriculteurs veulent ça parce qu'ils ont
pas de personnel je me fais je me fais
l'avocat encore quand vous avez un drone
qui passe au dessus de votre chambre et
qui dit voilà bah là il faudrait mettre
un petit peu plus d'engrais là il faudra
peut-être mettre un peu moins ce qui se
passe alors
téléphone et analyser un seul à partir
d'un drone faut quand même arrêter de se
[__] de la gueule des gens on analyse
pas un seul par un drone des trous voyez
donc c'est c'est tout ça c'est du
greenwashing c'est mais c'est du
mensonge c'est pas la vérité mais on
fait la même chose moi je trouve bon ça
me choque énormément alors on dit c'est
parce que il y a plus de médecins je
veux dire dans les maisons de retraite
et tout on est on est en train de
promouvoir ça c'est à dire que les
personnes âgées vont mettre leurs doigts
on dit ben votre peau est de temps ils
vont se mettre on va aller prendre en
photo puis un médecin au bout du fil qui
regarde en disant bon ben ça va mais il
y a plus de contact et le sol c'est
pareil comment comment on peut
comprendre un sol et les drones par
exemple et les plans mais par exemple un
drone si survole et qui voit par une
chambre une tâche très verte dans un
champ le beau ou très jaune mais par
exemple je prends le donc là le drone va
dire bon bah c'est bien seul profond
profondeur de sol mais c'est pas
forcément ça nous on l'a vu plusieurs
fois c'est que on a des résurgences on a
ce qu'on appelle des mouillères c'est à
dire une zone qui est très humide et qui
permet en fait même si le sol est pas
profond mais dans cet endroit là et bien
en fait on a une humidité et le sol
étant humide et aussi plus plus souple
moins sec et la plante va pousser mais
le drone a dit seul profond
et donc ces zones avec par exemple le
réchauffement qui vont s'assécher d'un
seul coup au bout de trois ans bah
deviennent jaunes comme le dessus donc
le conseil la vision du drone va être
elle est pas réelle dans dans ce qui se
passe en profondeur et moi je suis très
sceptique maintenant paraît-il que des
drones en survolant disent vous avez
tant de calcium assimilable tant de fer
assimila comment c'est possible avec la
couleur du sol mais c'est pas le sol
c'est quand même très complexe c'est pas
c'est pas comme une machine où on met il
manque un boulon on va mettre un boulon
c'est pas comme ça que ça fonctionne et
en plus les analyses sont très vicieuses
les analyses donnent les résultats pour
les agriculteurs en ppm on leur dit
partie
etc la victoire est incapable de savoir
ce que c'est qu'une partie par million
il a pas d'information scientifique pour
comprendre nous c'est pas ça qu'on fait
nous on mesure on mesure les teneurs en
éléments sur la hauteur jusqu'à la
limite des racines et on va lui donner
les résultats en kilos par hectare donc
quand on dit un agriculteur vous avez
une tonne 5 de potasses à l'hectare il
sait très bien qu'il a pas besoin d'en
racheter mais quand quand l'analyse lui
dit
150 ppm le ayant lui dit il faut en
mettre il en met il dit parce qu'il sait
pas lire le PPM donc c'est comme ça
qu'on les vole aussi on leur on leur dit
pas la vérité alors ce qui est important
pour l'anecdo c'est de connaître ses
réserves en kilos hectares parce que ça
il a une idée il sait combien une plante
a besoin en potasse en phosphore en
azote mais on se garde bien de lui dire
donc avec un drone vous dit les riches
en calcium et alors si tes racines sont
sur 20 cm on s'en fout ça manquera de
calcium si les racines sont sur un mètre
50 d'accord mais c'est pas un drone qui
sait jusqu'où des plonge les racines
d'ailleurs c'est le c'est l'avantage
parce que des gens toutes les analyses
de temps en temps on fait ça dans le
laboratoire dans notre laboratoire et
souvent les agriculteurs quand ils nous
appellent ils sont dans une situation un
peu compliquée on leur dit est-ce que
vous avez eu est-ce que vous avez fait
des analyses de sol
de votre terre ou de votre sol et nous
amène les analyses faites par un par un
organisme agréé on va dire et on regarde
les teneurs puis on dit bon bah nous on
va pas travailler tout à fait de la même
façon on va faire un profil et on leur
dit on lui demande mais vous avez envoyé
quelqu'un est venu mais il dit non j'ai
pris la carrière donc c'est un outil qui
tourne qui fait comme une carotte mais
une taille intérieure sur un seul
compact c'est une grosse vite on va
prélever là dessus
quand ça va bien vous en fait beaucoup
des trucs comme ça ben nous pas du tout
jamais jamais donc on a mesuré sur 30 cm
et on va donner des résultats mais très
souvent les 30 cm sur tout par exemple
après une moisson le blé il a tout
prélevé donc souvent vous êtes il va y
avoir des carreaux mais si vous faites
un profil d'un maître minimum un mec
mais quand on peut c'est un mètre 50
puis on va regarder même si le blé a été
coupé on va regarder à quelle profondeur
a été la racine si la racine et les
descendue à un mètre et que l'analyse de
sol a été 30 cm
en fait on considère que la racine elle
s'est nourrie que sur 30 cm mais si vous
avez mesuré à un mètre donc là vous
allez regarder par exemple le magnésium
combien j'en ai à ce moment-là mais ce
que j'en ai beaucoup en profondeur et si
j'ai la racine qui a été jusque là elle
peut se nourrir de ce magnésium donc ces
analyses sur 30 cm c'est quelque part un
vol pour l'agriculteur parce que très
souvent le conseil c'est il vous manque
de donc il faut que vous en rajoutiez
quand vous voyez les les robots des
herbeurs de mauvaises herbes il y a des
mauvaises herbes ou toutes les les
toutes les plantes sont pas mauvaises
elles sont indicatrices elles nous
parlent enfin elle nous parle vous avez
des si un seul bon là l'exemple on va
dire elle est plus simple si vous avez
un sol ou il y a plein de chardons
vous avez quelqu'un mais même
l'agriculteur il va dire bon bah il est
compact parce que le chardon c'est
carrément comme une une comment on
appelle ça une personne ça fait une
énorme racine et pour décompacter et
dans le livre de je le prononce très mal
idealawan qui était un
Égyptien qui a écrit trois volumes de
d'une agriculture
respectueuse et pour l'aider en fait il
prenait dans les zones très difficiles
qui avaient des charnons il coupait le
chardon au ras du sol il mettait la
graine de courge ou de céréales et elle
prenait le chemin qui avait fait bon la
racine de du Chardon comme il était
coupé elle était mort c'était quand même
incroyable c'est-à-dire qu'on permettait
dans un sol très très dur grâce à ces
racines de prendre de prendre un chemin
vous avez beaucoup de taupes chez vous
sur votre sol ça veut dire
essentiellement de vers blanc et de vers
de terre
pour une autre plante quand on a un sol
et qu'on a on connaît la géologie par
exemple qu'on a regardé et que on sait
que c'est d'après les cartes parce que
on utilise ça c'est un argilo calcaire
donc normalement il y a du calcaire en
surface et ça veut dire qu'on a un pH
qui est plutôt basique supérieur à 7 et
normalement une plante comme l'oxalis
qui est une plante qui a besoin d'un pH
acide
ne devrait pas pousser sur ce sol donc
déjà pour nous c'est une indication en
disant si on est sur un argile au
calcaire comme on l'a vu et qu'on a de
l'oxalis ça veut dire que en fait le
l'agriculteur
perd son calcium il est en acidification
de son sol par des pratiques parce qu'il
y a plus de faune il a plus de il a pu
cette faune et ses microbes qui
remontent les éléments le calcium est en
train de partir donc pour nous après
dans l'analyse on va voir
qu'effectivement le pH est acide en
surface il est basique en profondeur que
le calcium se laisser et donc là on dit
vous êtes en dégradation chimique donc
faites attention
question internet on va en piquer une
juste là puis on remontera la liste un
peu plus tard qu'est-ce que vous pensez
des de la culture en openfield
ça vous parle on sent ouvert pas du tout
parce qu'il entend par open question
pour sauver l'agriculture française et
ses seules faut-il sortir de la PAC
te
les grands groupes agroalistes
c'est vrai que la subvention
mais c'est pas la Pâque la France par
exemple donne des subventions à la
lituriologique avec trois ans de retard
alors qu'elle donne immédiatement les
subventions aux agriculteurs qui sont en
chimiques c'est que la France encourage
l'agriculture chimique et de pesticides
et elle décourage les gens de passer en
biologie bon ça déjà mais ça c'est la
France qui fait ça l'Autriche ne le fait
pas l'Allemagne ne le fait pas l'Italie
non plus donc ça c'est vraiment un
système français parce que la FNSEA est
complètement maquée avec l'agro
industrie et donc
c'est des preuves de ça déjà ils sont
dans les mêmes bâtiments c'est comme
étonnant ils sont venus Iéna dans le
même bâtiment que le Gnis
ça fait le glisse et
on choisit pas ses voisins
vous avez raison
l'UPP l'Union des industries
productrices de pesticides qui viennent
faire du greenwashing qui s'appelle
maintenant l'Union
des Industries oui des industries
protectrices des plantes comme
gremushing au lieu d'être productrices
de pesticides comme il voit que si ça
protège les plantes
on peut pas dire que c'est des poisons
les fongicides tous les champignons les
insecticides tous les poisons
c'est pas c'est pas des phytos c'est pas
des médicaments ce sont des poisons des
médicaments là-bas c'est des poisons non
ah non mais pas un poison médicament si
vous si vous avez
de l'acidité gastrique et quand vous met
et quand vous m'aide une base mais ça
dépend de magnésium etc c'est pas un
poison c'est pas un poison c'est un
médicament il vous soigne il faut pas
confondre un poison le cyanure est un
poison
il peut être utilisé pour
l'anesthésie
on peut pas faut être moins catégorique
que ça effectivement là tu es quand même
tu es trop catégorique effectivement il
y a des plantes qui sont utilisées à
faible dose qui peuvent faire quelque
chose et par exemple on a parlé un petit
peu de biodynamie les biodynamistes vont
la biodynamie on peut on comprend alors
il y a des gens
par rapport à comment sont préparés ces
fameux préparats on pourrait le
schématiser c'est
l'homéopathie mais il y a des gens
petite quantité et un produit il peut
être il peut être mis en petite quantité
et il va être bénéfique
et il peut vous le prenez beaucoup il va
devenir toxique et dans la médication
c'est ça si vous prenez trop d'un
médicament et bien vous allez ça peut ça
peut être dangereux question très
intéressée dans des internautes bonjour
de la Polynésie française on les
embrasse d'ailleurs les Bourbon les
Bourguignons ont-ils plusieurs
conférences en cours sur les sols
tropicaux
on ne peut appeler par les pays pour
faire des conférences sur les sols
tropicaux on est appelés au Brésil on
appelait en Argentine et on travaille on
travaille beaucoup sur les salles trois
petits cochons complètement différentes
travail à la ville de La Réunion on
travaille sur Guadeloupe Martinique un
peu et rien de Mayotte d'ailleurs
on brasse
Daoudi Mamoudzou
on les embrasse fort mais c'est vrai
qu'on ne c'est vrai qu'on a vraiment
besoin parce que c'est scandaleux ce
qu'on fait dans les pays tropicaux quand
vous pensez que la Guadeloupe pourrait
nourrir tout sa population en produisant
du riz et qui a pas de culture du riz à
la Guadeloupe c'est quand même c'est pas
normal quand vous voyez des serres qui
sont plantés en petits tropicales dans
un pays où il fait chaud humide on n'a
pas besoin de serre et une fois que vous
avez mis une servi tropicale faut la
refroidir faut la rafraîchir faut pomper
de l'eau pour arroser enfin là on marche
sur la tête là je vais vous raconter une
année une anecdote
pour on était on nous a demandé de
c'était
un festival de de films un peu engagés
et d'un film engagés
c'était sur
nos enfants nous accuseront
le film solution locale pour un désordre
global un film qui avait été fait par
des Brésiliens mais je ne me rappelle
pas donc sur la canne à sucre le
problème de la canne à sucre
qui était utilisé à un moment où un peu
moins mais comme comme fournitures de
d'énergie et en fait on nous avait
demandé de d'aller donc en Guadeloupe
pour commenter puisqu'on était dans un
des films si et donc
on se promène quand même et on regarde
un nombre de jachères enfin de plans pas
de terre où il y avait rien en fait
enchère en friche à l'intérieur du pays
et tout et on se dit mais quand même ça
représente un certain pourcentage je
sais pas il y avait 15 % on nous demande
on nous dit oui ben il y a 15 %
et donc on regarde quand même parce que
toujours c'est une vocation on a regardé
on a gratté la terre on va pouvoir un
peu et le soir de la conférence donc il
y avait plein plein de gens et tout et
enfin de truc il y a un moment les gens
ont parlé de la dépendance de la
Guadeloupe de la Martinique entre autres
pour le riz qu'ils achètent chez nous en
France mais qui en achètent beaucoup au
Brésil et là on dit mais de façon naïve
c'est la France oui mais
bon sur la métropole voilà excusez-moi
sur la métropole vous avez raison j'ai
fait et on dit mais pourquoi pourquoi en
fait vous ne cultivez pas de riz vous
avez énormément de terre en attente qui
sont on a regardé on pourrait faire du
riz il y avait des personnes qui
subventionnaient de ce festival et qui
était de l'INRA en trop qui se lève et
qui disent mais c'est n'importe quoi les
Bourguignons il y a jamais jamais et ils
insistent de riz planter en Guadeloupe
donc là Amiens quand même et là il y a
une dame qui était un peu âgée qui se
lève et qui dit monsieur vous avez tort
donc tout de suite il dit maintenant
j'ai pas tort et elle dit vous voyez je
suis âgée mais mes parents donc il y
avait et elle parlait de sa grand-mère
on mangeait du riz de Guadeloupe
donc ça veut dire que mais
c'est peut-être plus facile de faire
venir donc dans des terrains dans et
à l'île de la Réunion il y a des des
cultures qui ne font plus du tout parce
que peut-être ils font du personnel mais
c'est quand même dommage et c'est c'est
ces îles comme la France importe en fait
du riz alors qu'il pourrait en faire il
pourrait se nourrir comment il vous
perçoivent vos collègues comment ils
vous perçoivent ils vous perçoivent pour
des comme des urberlus comme des
précurseurs il vous perçoivent comme des
menaces pour leur propre perception leur
propre analyse ou comme des alliés ou
comme quelqu'un qui pense en dehors de
la boîte
décalage qui se fait entre la le
potentiel génétique et la production
réelle donc c'est que ça va pas parce
qu'ils ont pas compris que le sol était
un facteur fondamental de la production
donc à l'heure actuelle ils ont des
Ferrari il roulent sur des chemins de
terre mais vous allez plus vite en deux
chevaux
donc il faut revenir sur des variétés
beaucoup plus rustiques beaucoup plus
simple refaire de la sélection massale
ils n'ont pas de la sélection la
sélection de clones et puis arrêter le
labour passer au semis direct sous
couvert ça on pourra peut-être vous en
parler de ce que c'est que le semis
direct sous couvert on va en parler mais
moi je vais vous rectifier c'est pas la
deux chevaux c'est la Diane
je vais vous l'enseignement de la
microbiologie des sols c'est c'est au
programme on lançait toujours on
l'enseigne mieux
comme vous dites on est on a on a été
énormément combattu mais
l'INRA qui Claude disait ça on
au niveau du travail c'était très très
compliqué pour Claude qui était en
microbiologie des sols on lui a proposé
d'arrêter d'être bibliothécaire donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a monté notre
entreprise on a quitté l'INRA moi je
travaillais sur la qualité des aliments
de l'homme et j'ai été je travaillais
quand il y a eu enfin ça remonte à trop
loin et puis ça sera peut-être un peu
long mais le problème qui a eu sur le
colza qui était riche en un acide gras
qui avait 22 atomes de 24 22 atomes de
carbone et qui provoquait sur un certain
nombre d'animaux le canard le rat le
cochon la souris des infiltrations
graisseuses sur le cœur et en fait comme
c'était
ah oui ah oui ça ça c'est sourcé
dans les années
60-70 et en fait on a continué à
cultiver cette variété de colza alors
que les il y a eu des séminaires qui
sont passés avec les scientifiques
monsieur roclin qui était qui était le
chef de de l'Institut national de
recherche agronomique à Dijon dans la
qualité des aliments de l'homme qui sont
partis avec l'équipe de valardingen et
ils sont partis au Canada pour parler de
ce problème et en fait les industriels
ont dit il y a eu un côté de ces
industriels en disant mais vous pouvez
pas sortir ces résultats on n'est pas il
y a rien d'autre et on a attendu que la
génétique sorte la variété primor la
première qui était faible en acide et
Russie et à ce moment-là on a dit aux
agriculteurs faut plus du tout planter
la première et il y a eu une réticence
même des agriculteurs parce que cette
variété après il y a eu le triple zéro
moi il y en a eu d'autres mais c'est de
variété au niveau au début avec moins de
rendement que la variété de colza qui
avait beaucoup d'acide russique donc en
fait les gens les agriculteurs ont
continué pendant un moment mais en fait
on a arrêté cette molécule face cette
semence pardon quand génétiquement on a
trouvé quelque chose on a laissé pendant
de nombreuses années utiliser ce colza
qui effectivement est-ce que c'est ne
pesait peut-être pas ça sur l'homme mais
quand vous avez cette jusqu'au singe qui
a ce genre de produit ben voilà et
mais maintenant l'INRA travaille
là-dessus dit que les études même sur la
biodynamie on va avoir plus d'activités
biologiques qui parlent de biodiversité
il parle de rotation chose qu'on disait
il y a 30 ans et on a été combattu donc
en fait quelque part même si on a été
convaincu on peut se dire que
assez extraordinaire qui est que elle
envoie des exils d'aracinaires dans leur
racine et elles vont nourrir le microbe
dont elles ont besoin donc on fait des
expériences simples on prend un symbiose
voilà c'est une symbiose ça y est on
prend on prend par exemple un blé qu'on
va cultiver hors sol et on va le
carencier en manganèse d'ailleurs la
solution nutritive on met pas de
manganèse il va commencer à avoir des
signes caractéristiques sur les feuilles
comme quoi il a une carence en manganèse
à ce moment-là vous prenez les racines
qui sont dans le vide dans le sang dans
les solutions électriques vous les
écrasez dans du sol et vous voyez se
multiplier les microbes qui qui Galates
le manganèse et qu'il donne aux plantes
et qui a un véritable dialogue entre la
plante et le microbe le gros problème de
ça c'est que ça rapporte rien c'est
totalement gratuit c'est simplement en
faisant des rotations si vous mettez par
du colza ça va stimuler il a besoin de
beaucoup de souffre il stimule les
bactéries du soufre si vous mettez une
légumineuse elle stimulait rhizome qui
fixe l'azote si la rotation elle va
permettre de maintenir une population
microbienne diverses qui fournit les
différents oligo-éléments donc vous
allez avoir une alimentation extrêmement
équilibrée vous allez avoir
des vins qui vont avoir vraiment en
bouge les toucher de bouche magnifique
des fruits parfumés etc parce que dans
la solution hors sol on ne sait pas
mettre les 24 éléments que le sol fourni
que les microbes du sol fournis on en
met à peu près une dizaine d'ailleurs
c'est intéressant dans les solutions
nutritives la dernière solution sans les
âges et ajoute le dernier moment parce
que sinon il y a des précipitations du
haut elle s'appelle quand même la
solution finale intéressante
et donc si vous voulez on n'arrivera
jamais à faire une solution
non non pas très rigolo c'est on
n'arrivera jamais à faire si vous voulez
si vous vouliez faire ce que les données
les 24 atomes que les microbes de nos
plantes ça coûterait une telle fortune
ces solutions nutritives là on pourrait
même pas là vous arrivez il y a des prix
de plantes absolument astronomiques quoi
donc on prend les on prend les éléments
qui sont le minimum de ce dont on a
besoin alors que le sol lui chaque sol
va avoir en fonction de la roche qu'il a
plus ou moins de manganèse plus ou moins
de coballe plus ou moins de il va donner
ce qu'on appelle le goût de terroir ce
goût très caractéristique que vous allez
avoir la fraise de fougastel elle a pas
le même goût que les fraises de Provence
votre femme a l'air pas d'accord non
parce que quand il dit si on mettait
après tu t'es un peu rattrapé parce que
en fait dans un sol vous avez pas
forcément les 24 éléments on est bien
d'accord donc en fait en fonction du
type de sol que vous avez vous avez
peut-être plus de magnésium dans
certains sols par exemple
ou d'autres et on va y avoir plus de fer
à un autre aura un peu plus de bord et
tout donc en fait c'est ça l'originalité
d'un terroir c'est pas de mettre une
solution nutritive qui aurait les 24
c'est en fait la typicité la notion de
terroir c'est ce qu'apporte le sol c'est
pas de donner tout ce que si on
connaissait tout et que on faisait même
cette solution nutritive on n'aurait
jamais la diversité de goût de texture
parce que ça serait
résistant parce que en fait quelque part
ça serait gavé la plante elle a parfois
des plantes n'ont pas forcément pour ça
là je te reprends j'ai une solution
nutritive un seul il est il est uniple
enfin bon il y en a qui se ressent mais
il y a un côté d'unicité du sol chaque
sol est différent et vont faire que
chaque agriculteur est différent en plus
le son travail va être différent et je
pense que si on a le mot terroir la
notion de terroir on l'a énormément
galvaudé tout le monde dit j'ai un grand
terroir et tout mais le mot terroir ne
se traduit pas et c'est la France qui a
vraiment mis en avant cette notion de
terroir avec parce qu'on est une jolie
géologie très diverse et que en fait les
agriculteurs ont fait des produits
terroir il parlait de la fraise de
Plougastel on part du melon de Cavaillon
et autrefois même les graines on va
revenir sur les graines les semences
paysannes c'est un catalogue mais là je
crois que c'est
comment il s'appelle celui qui faisait
j'ai une référence d'un catalogue qui
donnait de 1903 et après c'est 1983 la
diminution du nombre de semences par
exemple pour la salade qui a énormément
diminué parce qu'il y avait des graines
de salade qui était pour le par exemple
la Bretagne et on avait des graines de
salade qui était pour pour la Bourgogne
on n'est pas sur le même climat et la
France a poussé le la notion de terroir
pour le vin ça a été absolument amené en
avant et on en parle beaucoup mais parce
que il y a une il y a il y a une
différence des sols on a des
concentrations très très différentes des
sols
question de Arthur bonjour pourquoi ne
sont-ils pas reconnus par les membres de
la FES associations française de l'étude
des sols
il faudrait lui demander pourquoi la
fesse ne s'occupe que de la dimension
physique et
ils ont fait un jeu de mots ça c'est
très très pédologue ça mais les qui veut
dire donc la science du sol en grec et
si vous voulez ils ont surtout une
approche physico-chimie du sol pas une
approche biologique donc
ça va évoluer c'est en train d'évoluer
ça y est je crois que les gens sont en
train de comprendre que la vie du sol
est fondamentale et que c'est ça qui
permet de créer comme dividir le goût de
terroir et le goût mais pour ça il faut
accepter de rentrer dans la
microbiologie des sols question internet
du coup c'est quoi le secret d'un
compost parfait selon Claude et Lydia
pour un potager ou pour un verger merci
pour l'émission
C'est incroyable parce que c'est la
question en réalité étonnante parce que
c'est des composts totalement différents
le maraîchage on mange les légumes verts
la salade n'attend pas qu'elle soit en
graines pour la manger en général et le
maraîchage et est une culture qui est je
dirais presque que sur du compost c'est
à dire qu'il faut que le compost il y en
ait beaucoup et qui soit très riche en
azote pour pouvoir faire
pour pouvoir faire ça par contre un
verger ou la vigne si on veut que il y
ait une concentration il faut que le
compost soit très riche en carbone donc
en ligne donc vous voyez ces deux
composts différents pour le type de
culture et quand nous on parle de ça les
gens disent ben nous on nous a dit de
mettre ce compost cela souvent le
compost est très très riche en azote
parce que ça va permettre la
minéralisation rapide de ce compost
puisqu'il y a beaucoup d'azote pour
nourrir plus rapidement la plante
puisqu'on minéralise et on ne va pas
stocker cette matière organique donc en
fait il y a il y a aussi une volonté
dans le compost de faire d'utiliser un
compost qui toute façon va favoriser
l'augmentation de la minéralisation de
cette matière organique et pour la vigne
on conseille surtout que les vignerons
ne veulent pas des raisins trop dilués
ils veulent de la concentration donc le
compost on va il faudra qu'il soit riche
en carbone donc on dit un carbone le
rapport carbone sur azote supérieure à
c'est à dire alors que maraîcher on va
lui dire 10 vous allez avoir beaucoup
plus d'azote et ce sera mieux pour pour
les légumes
pour aller je jusque là
[Musique]
impacter parce que ça lui fait remonter
ses racines maintenant le labour pour
les céréales il y en a plus besoin
maintenant qu'on sait travailler en
semis direct sous couvert on a pu besoin
de la bourrer
alors direction couvert on explique ça
veut dire quoi donc si vous voulez
depuis 7000 ans le problème de l'homme
c'est créer un lit de semences pour
qu'elle aille la graine puisse germer
c'est
je me marre parce que c'est la manière
dont
il est donc tu pars sur ta tête voilà
vas-y vous faites un très beau couple
c'est bien passé la Saint-Valentin hier
on était pas vraiment on
est avec on a été à la coupole avec des
amis on était bien parce que tu es passé
du cheval
sans
été et pourquoi parce que je pense que
quand il y a des questions comme ça le
cheval et on nous l'a dit plus d'une
fois mais vous vous rendez pas compte
surtout quand c'est labouré c'est pas le
cheval de course c'est le gros
et les gens disent mais ça pèse je sais
pas
100 kg donc c'est plus lourd qu'un ça va
être plus lourd qu'un petit tracteur
donc votre cheval quand vous dites qu'il
compacte pas on ne croit pas mais le
problème du cheval bon c'est ce qu'il a
dit il vibre pas mais un cheval ne pose
rarement comme ça il fait ça et il
pousse comme ça donc la pression n'est
pas en même temps et la pression elle
est dégagée donc en fait il y a moins de
placement et
ça se voit voilà tu as vu la taille d'un
savon par rapport à une route tracteur
vous connaissez le rôle l'amortisseur de
la fourchette
donc le semis direct vas-y donc vous
êtes marié
[Musique]
ensemble 24 heures
j'apprécie beaucoup de voir ça je suis
désolé vous faites rougir
Claude
agriculteur c'est deux choses il faut
qu'il crée un lit de semences pour que
la graine puisse germer c'est-à-dire un
sol qui ne soit pas trop compact il y a
plus d'air et la graine jamais pas trop
souffler si dans la graine se dessèche
donc ça c'est ce qu'on appelle le lit de
semences il faut pas qu'il y ait des
adventiste qui est d'état de des plantes
qui poussent plus vite que ça graine
donc pour lutter contre ça l'homme il a
d'abord travaillé à la houppe l'année
qui gratouillait la terre pour se
débarrasser des adventices et puis au
fur et à mesure des progrès techniques
on est passé à l'âne puis au cheval et
ensuite à la machine qu'il aborde de
plus en plus profondément et c'est là
qu'on a commencé vraiment à faire les
bêtises donc la grande ce qui va être la
grande évolution agronomique dans le
seuil qui va venir c'est arrêter
complètement de la bourre et créer le
lit de semences grâce à des plans qu'on
appelle des plantes de couverture sur
des plantes qui font énormément de
racines qui a énormément la surface du
sol et le principe est le suivant
derrière la moisson on va tout de suite
on n'attend pas que le sol se dessèche
tout derrière le lasseuse batteuse on
s'aime une culture qui va profiter des
derniers jours chauds pour produire de
la biomasse on va lui donner à manger en
localisé avec le semoir c'est semoir
spéciaux on est semoir à disque qui
n'ouvre qui fonde le sol et à une roue
derrière qui referme on donne à manger à
la plante bah c'est plus rien à manger
le blé à tout consommer et il va elle va
pousser pendant tout l'été elle va
continuer à faire de la biomasse et à
l'automne au mois d'octobre on va
écraser à l'avant du tracteur on met une
on met un rouleau qu'on appelle un
rouleau fracasse un rouleau qui est fait
avec des bornes coupantes qui écrase la
plante de couverture qu'il a tue et on
va semer directement dans la culture
d'hiver donc le sol est tout le temps
occupé par des plantes c'est de prendre
de couverture récupère les engrais qui
en profondeur enfin les aliments qui en
profondeur et les en surface et on va
monter doucement doucement le taux de
matière organique puisqu'on est en air
plus le sol on le brûle plus la matière
organique et on va augmenter le taux de
matière organique c'est-à-dire qu'on va
copier ce qui se passe dans la nature
alors c'est très c'est vraiment il faut
être très bon agriculteur pour faire ça
faut avoir un semoir spécial il faut
avoir ce rouleau à l'avant pour écraser
mais c'est la grande révolution agricole
de l'histoire mais évidemment l'agro
industrie veut pas entendre parler parce
qu'on consomme moins d'engrais plus
besoin de gros tracteur puisqu'on a
juste à tirer un semoir on a donc
économie la moissonneuse batteuse de
moissonne que les épis on a besoin de la
paille pour protéger le solde
hydratation donc grosso moins d'essence
pour donner une idée on passe de 125
litres de fuel à l'hectare à 25 litres
donc toute la Grouin de ce qui est
autour ne voit ça d'un très très
mauvaise oeil donc on a beaucoup de mal
à développer cette technique
mais on moins de tout ça
vous avez vu les courbes il y a moins de
choses balancées dans la nature parce
qu'en fait c'est un peu plus concentré
donc ça pèse moins lourd c'est ça c'est
ça le le fait de manche c'est ça c'est
ça ok c'est ce que j'avais compris vous
confirmer mais en fait on en met moi
mais c'est plus concentré
je crois que ça a été démontré
effectivement avant on mettait quelqu'un
je me rappelle plus qui est sur une
vidéo il y a quelqu'un qui disait avant
on mettait l'équivalent d'une tour
Eiffel en poids puis maintenant il dit
avec une pièce c'est la même le même
pouvoir le même pouvoir j'ose pas dire
side que ce qu'on mettait mais c'est
aussi violent voire plus violent mais
dans le semis direct sous couvert ce que
Claude a dit peut-être a oublié de dire
c'est que pour un agriculteur c'est
quand même très très compliqué c'est à
dire il peut pas faire de monoculture
très compliqué parce que comme on laisse
les pailles quand même il faut que la
faune surtout quand ça démarre quand on
laisse les pailles sur le sol il faut
qu'elles aient le temps de se décomposer
et même si le couvert vient dessus donc
si on fait de la monoculture on risque
si on fait du maïs toujours en semis
direct on risque de
d'avoir une des maladies sur l'année
d'après donc ça c'est le premier point
et le début du semis direct sous couvert
en fait il y a eu et c'est plus l'Europe
et la France qui a travaillé là-dessus
on a travaillé quand on était en
Argentine là là-bas et d'ailleurs en
Argentine
au Brésil on est parti en 2000 j'ai fait
un j'ai organisé un voyage avec des
agriculteurs français et les gens de
l'Agence française du développement
apprenant ce voyage ce sont dessus et on
les a emmenés je les ai emmenés avec
Claude bien sûr on est parti de Punta
allègre et on est monté juste sur le
front amazonien pour rencontrer des
agriculteurs qui faisaient du semis
direct sous couvert parce que en 2000
quand on disait ça aux agriculteurs les
gens disaient non mais là les
Bourguignons ils fument la moquette pour
vraiment ils sont complètement ça
n'existe pas et on a dit bon ben vous
emmener dans des chez des agriculteurs
qui ne font que ça c'est à dire il amour
plus et pour des raisons pour des
raisons économiques et
mais les plantes de couverture donc ce
couvert qui mettait entre la la plante
qui
voulait c'était de voir une espèce ou
voir maximum de la réussite en France
est de mélanger dans le couvercle au
moins 6 espèces donc on va mettre par
exemple un colza qui va avoir une racine
pivotante qui va descendre à un certain
niveau on va mettre une céréale qui a
une racine qui est très chevelue on va
mettre une légumineuse qui lui elle va
apporter de l'azote donc en fait on fait
un mix de ce couvert qui va non
seulement augmenter la matière organique
mais qui va permettre grâce à ses
racines quand ce sera coupé au sol de
remonter les éléments et ça permet un
peu de on peut faire deux années mais on
peut pas faire de la monoculture pendant
parce qu'en fait cette biodiversité va
permettre de calmer entre entre deux
plans mais la réussite c'est ça
ce qui ne va pas et qui enfin c'est pas
qui ne va pas qui a qui ça ne s'est pas
développé parce que au Brésil en Brésil
Argentine
Uruguay qui développe énormément ça pour
détruire le couvert ils utilisaient du
glyphosate et donc enfin bon cette
molécule qui qui anherbicide cette
herbicide et en fait dans ces pays-là
surtout l'Argentine a été un moment un
laboratoire
pour ces
herbicide avec le développement de du
semis direct parce qu'on a dit votre
couvert vous allez pas passer un rouleau
FACA vous allez le griller vous allez le
brûler puis vous aimerez directement
dessus et en Europe on a pris cet
argument pour ne pas valoriser le semis
direct ce couvert en disant mais on est
obligé d'utiliser cette herbicide qui
n'est qui est effectivement toxique mais
si on met un outil qui écrase et bien à
ce moment-là on peut se dédouaner de
cette herbicides
on parle de tout ce qui finit en si de
pesticides
mais dans l'agriculture il y a des
calamités il y a des vermines il y a des
maladies est-ce que votre méthode permet
de se protéger de tout ça la rotation
c'était la méthode que les paysans
avaient mis au point pour éviter
justement
que ce soit toujours la même plante qui
a-t-il toujours les mêmes parasites donc
ils pratiquaient ce qu'on appelle la
rotation et l'association telle que par
exemple dans les céréales il y avait un
nom pour chaque association le Morgane
on mélangeait par exemple une
épée comme triptycom Qualita qui lui
faisait le rendement les années sèches
on mettait à cet homme qui faisait les
rendements les années moyenne et un
estivum les années les années humides et
donc on mettait pas tous ces œufs dans
le même panier et donc on avait une
association d'espèces les parasites
avaient beaucoup plus de mal à se mettre
dedans donc c'était la rotation et
l'association a été complètement oublié
par la grande amie moderne mais c'est la
base c'est le fondement de la grande mie
de durable c'est que justement vous
allez pour lutter contre les parasites
vous allez faire des rotations et des
associations et moi je poserai aussi la
question autrement un pourquoi pourquoi
on attend de maladie
sur les plantes si on bascule autrefois
quand même les anciens n'avaient
absolument pas toutes ces molécules pour
pour lutter contre les champignons
contre
oui mais il y avait une meilleure
effectivement il faisait ils étaient
dans la biodiversité ils ont une ils
avaient ils aient des rotations mais moi
je me pose quand même la question
pourquoi pourquoi on a tant de maladie
le lien au matériel végétal là je vais
parler pour la vigne la vigne en fait il
y a un vrai problème il y a des
problèmes pour le sol mais il y a et
tous les vignerons le disent on a un
problème avec le matériel végétal le
matériel végétal tombe tout de suite
malade pourquoi on a on a ce problème
qui n'existait pas la vigne c'est pas
c'est pas c'est une monoculture mais
c'est pas des rendements forcément moi
je me pose la question il y a les sols
il y a aussi le matériel végétal ce que
les agriculteurs mettent maintenant
quand leur donne qu'on leur vend il y a
une fragilité il y a plus de fragilité
qu'avant moi j'en suis persuadée
beaucoup plus résilience que le clone
quand vous voyez toutes ces banques de
graines un peu partout dans le monde
en Antarctique je crois ou Oswald barde
c'est bien c'est pas bien ça nous
protège c'est au cas où c'est quoi moi
je pense que
c'est pour se limer c'est pour se donner
bonne conscience une graine si vous la
faites pas pousser si le vous la faites
pas se multiplier il y a un moment elle
peut
elle va pas il faut qu'elle il faut là
il faut la cultiver il faut la il faut
qu'elle
se garde 2000
certaines graines
des graines plantées par les Indiens
sous un espèce de vase qu'ils ont été
dans les dans les tombeaux égyptiens on
a retrouvé effectivement
des graines qu'on a pu qu'on a pu
certaines graines les graines de
légumineuses par exemple les graines
grasses comme les haricots c'est souvent
des céréales c'est souvent des graisses
céréales qu'on a remarqué
dure mais il y a des plantes si vous les
reproduisez pas régulièrement tous les
quatre cent quatre ans cinq ans
il y a un jour vous allez rien récupérer
et il y a des scientifiques qui se
posent la question en disant si en fait
on fait pas faire un cycle
parce que quand même la un blé ou une
céréale ou un haricots en fait on va
mettre une graine et puis il va en faire
il va faire plusieurs haricots c'est
d'ailleurs c'est quand même incroyable
c'est c'est la magie de la nature avec
un grain de blé on fait on en fait 10 ou
20 donc centrale
non mais qu'on fasse des collections ça
c'est sûr mais c'est collections ça
demande de l'entretien faut les
recultiver régulièrement faut c'est du
boulot faut pas se contenter de mettre
ça dans des frigos et penser que tout va
très bien se passer ça c'est c'est
encore du rêve technologique ça il faut
pas si on se prend une une bominette
nucléaire ça peut toujours servir ça
pourrait servir est-ce que ce sera drôle
de vivre après une bombinette nucléaire
c'est la question qu'on a le droit de se
poser
question quand on voit le réchauffement
climatique arriver plein de balle les
méga bassines c'est une bonne idée c'est
pas une bonne idée
c'est n'importe quoi
selon vous c'est n'importe quoi
on prend de la fin on les remplit avec
la nappe phréatique
et puis la pluie vous avez les vacations
c'est pour éviter que ça se baigne en
mer non
oui mais vous pompez la nappe phréatique
et vous êtes sans arrêt presque tous les
ans vous êtes condamnés à pas arroser
votre jardin les vignerons là c'est
cette année en 2022 des interdictions
complètes et c'est avec les bassines
qu'on pense qu'on va régler le problème
là il y a c'est pareil là il y a enfin
pour nous c'est circuler pour mieux
sauter c'est le maïs c'est une plante de
milieu sec c'est une plante qui a pas
besoin d'eau qui vit dans les dans les
zones
sélectionner faire de la sélection en
milieu sec du maïs le sorgho résisterait
bien la sécheresse est-ce qu'on est on a
rendu le maïs sensible à l'eau pour
effectivement augmenter les rendements
mais baisser aussi la qualité est-ce
qu'on peut pas plutôt faire une
sélection de ces maïs paysans continuent
la sélection massale tranquillement en
milieu sec et vous aurez des maïs de
plus en plus résistants au sec alors là
il vous raconte que avec les maïs OGM
ils vont vous faire du maïs résistant au
sec mais attendez le je crois que c'est
plus de 30 gènes qui contrôlent la
résistance au sec ils vont jamais
pouvoir manipuler ça là c'est là c'est
la fake news il faut retravailler en
milieu donné comment on a réussi à faire
monter le le maïs jusque jusqu'au
Danemark par des paysans je crois que
c'est l'année je suis il y a une année
dans les années 40 qui a été
particulièrement particulièrement sèche
et il y avait les agriculteurs qui
étaient sur la Montagne Noire et qui
n'arrivait jamais à faire mûrir leur
maïs donc il le donnait comme pâture
alors alors va être il les coupait pied
d'un coup il y a une année
particulièrement sèche ou dans la
Montagne Noire ils ont fait un très beau
rendement maïs ils ont gardé ça ils ont
créé une variété de maïs qui a permis de
monter parce que pousser en altitude qui
a permis de monter des paysans qui l'ont
fait c'est pas des ingénieurs donc on a
tendance à croire que comme nous sommes
technologies nous nous transformons la
technologie en une religion c'est très
mauvais de devoir qu'on va aller sur
Mars on va régler tous les
je repose la question que pense-t-il des
openfield alors je sais pas ce que c'est
la traduction s'échange ouvert
je pense que c'est ça les films
quand on voit quand on voit le
les maraîchers être exposés au prix du
des engrais parce qu'il y a la crise en
Russie ils se disent on va pas semer
parce que on va pas pouvoir répercuter
les prix
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez leur dire
on prend non à l'état de les aider pour
qu'il régénère les sols on fait quoi
quel est quelle est la stratégie de
guerre des agriculteurs pour aider la
France à résister à la guerre économique
qu'on est en train de subir est-ce
qu'ils doivent changer de culture se
mettre en économie vivrière de guerre
c'est-à-dire on veut dire Aurus ok vous
restez dans votre coin vous engrais vous
les gardez votre dièse vous le gardez il
faut mettre notre industrie on va dire
de du manger en économie de guerre
qu'est-ce qu'il faut planter
c'est comment on va faire pour nourrir
ses plantes depuis 150 ans nous avons
inventé le tout-à-l'égout qui est une
véritable catastrophe et c'est toutes
les richesses que produit la terre qui
autrefois autrefois les maraîchers de
Paris ils descendaient tous les jours
portaient leurs légumes et remonter les
crottes de chevaux qu'on le mettait dans
des sacs en cuir dans le coin du chaud
le crottin et il récupérait tous les
excréments des gens et les urines dans
les dans les tinettes en fond de cours
ça c'était remonté il remontait en
moyenne 100 tonnes de 100 tonnes de
comme les Mayas et ça ça a duré pendant
plus de plus de 2000 ans et ça nourrit
Paris ça nourrit toutes les villes
d'européennes et puis on invente le
tout-à-l'égout c'est on copie les romans
fait la même erreur que les Romains qui
ont ruiné et romains ont décidé
d'envoyer tout dans les rivières ça fait
150 ans que tout ce que nous mangeons et
qui vient de la terre parlons les
rivières alors on fait des stations
d'épuration prennent les stations
d'épuration c'est que nous mélangeons
les déchets industriels avec des déchets
humains comme nous avons des toilettes
humides des toilettes dans l'eau tout
l'azote s'évapore sous forme de sous
forme d'ammoniacale alors qu'avant ils
allaient dans des tinettes sèches et
donc ils gardaient leur azote donc nous
avons organisé un système
d'appauvrissement des sols en envoyant
tout dans la mer donc première chose que
doit faire un gouvernement arrêter le
tout-à-l'égout composter tout ce qui
vient des villes pour pouvoir le
remettre dans les terres de maraîchage
et là je peux vous dire que ça pousse
mais c'est spectaculaire c'est
spectaculaire les gens qu'on nettoie de
sèche il y a des gens qui font des du
maraîchage pour eux ils ont des
toilettes sèches ils gardent ils broie
les tous les branches des arbres pour
faire du bois ramé alfragmenter qui
mélange avec la toilette je vais vous
dire que ça pousse mais incroyable
vous rendez compte que 19e on produisait
10 fois plus de légumes au mètre carré
comme maintenant 10 fois plus il faisait
9 cultures par an il n'arrêtaient pas
n'arrêtez pas il cultivait il cultivait
cultiver des couches chaudes pour
pouvoir produire en hiver il faut il
faisait chauffer le crottin de cheval
pour que ça chauffe et produire
c'est le livre de
l'agriculture de Duverne
extraordinaire le 19e est un grand sec
pour l'agriculture et puis on a tous
laissé tomber on a dit non on va mettre
des engrais chimiques c'est plus simple
et envoyer tous nos excréments et notre
urine à la mer mais c'est ça dérange
comme ça système aberrant
bon une culture en France qu'on doit
mettre absolument par rapport au
réchauffement climatique il faut qu'on
se mette à cultiver quoi en France avec
l'augmentation des températures
remettre des légumineuses
remettre les lentilles du puits et en
plus remettre des légumes des
légumineuses oui mettre de la luzerne
pour passer une plante
qui remonte du magnésium en
[Musique]
urgence refaire de la prairie refaire du
foin refaire du foin ce qu'on ne fait
plus c'est pour ça que les abeilles sont
en train de disparaître c'est que le
foie c'est-à-dire on laissait autrefois
l'herbe monter en fleurs
ça nourrissait les abeilles
ça nourrissa les abeilles on avait du
miel et le foin c'est ça permet le
retour des accrédiens c'était des
sauterelles des critères qui a
énormément les soldes et qui permet
aussi les cultures les autres
mais pas si vous inquiétez pas quand il
y a des oiseaux qui sont occupent et des
animaux encore qui des oiseaux
etc qui contrôle toutes ces populations
donc c'est c'est vrai qu'il y a des il
faut refaire du foin il faut arrêter
l'ensilage l'ensilage empêche les
abeilles de se nourrir c'est pas bien on
a besoin de pollinisateur pour
polliniser donc là il faut revenir au
foin
est-ce que est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous pensez du label hte
haute valeur environnementale
j'en profite je vous garde
en fait c'est la région de Bordeaux qui
a mis ça en place après le bordeaux
bashing qui a été qui a été fait sur
surtout sur la vigne parce que au niveau
des produits de traitement donc en fait
on le retorise on leur autorise
certaines molécules qui sont qui sont
contestés à des doses plus faibles mais
en fait
nous pour l'instant on pense que que
c'était pas ça mais là il y a on a des
gens qui nous disent que c'est la haute
valeur
environnementale ils sont en train de
mettre des normes qui sont de plus en
plus sévères
c'est des vignerons pardon excusez-moi
les vignerons parce qu'en fait
la haute valeur environnementale elle a
été surtout pour les vignerons au départ
après peut-être que c'est étendu mais
c'est surtout les vignerons qui en
parlent
et là ils sont en train de durcir
labeline maintenant il se rendent compte
que pour être crédible il faut quand
même qu'ils mettent des normes et qui
baisse les doses donc ça c'est bien ça
les vignerons qui étaient en biologie en
fait on
se se sont manifestés
en biologie c'est à dire sans produit de
sans vraiment sans produits de
traitement ce sont un peu mobilisés en
disant si c'est ça si c'est pour ce
verdir on passe en là je vais et bien en
fait ça va pas parce qu'en fait ils
auront toujours ils ont toujours le
droit d'utiliser ces molécules à plus
faible dose mais ils ont le droit de
l'utiliser et
apparemment il y aurait un durcissement
de de ce label
c'est bien question internet combien
d'agriculture d'agriculteurs food ou
d'agricultrices d'ailleurs
faudrait-il pour nourrir la France avec
une agriculture non industrielle
de le dire disons que avant l'industrie
il y avait 6 millions d'agriculteurs qui
nourrissaient 30 millions de 30 millions
de Français et après il y a eu le
progrès alors après il les engrais
chimiques l'entrée du pétrole dans
l'agriculture mais de toute façon de
toute façon à l'heure actuelle les 300
000 agriculteurs qui nous restent en
France ne nourrissent pas les français
puisque nous importons à peu près la
moitié de notre viande 40% de nos fruits
aux légumes donc la France est produit
quoi le produit du maïs qui va aux
animaux produits de la betterave et du
sucre c'est pas c'est pas très
passionnant elle fait elle fait des
céréales mais comme elles sont pas très
bonne qualité on a perdu les grands
marchés c'est l'Ukraine qui nous a pris
le marché de l'Egypte qui était le
marché le plus payant en blé donc on a
on a perdu on était les premiers
producteurs de pommes en 1960 on est
maintenant en sixième position on était
premier producteur d'asperges pareil on
est dépassé par la Pologne si vous
voulez l'agriculture française c'est un
désastre depuis 70 ans donc on apporte
ton importe on importe et je dis c'est
pas je pense je pense que le choix qui a
été fait de confier l'agriculteur à
l'agro-industrie d'accord industrie
qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait elle a fait
comme toutes les industries elle s'est
occupée de ses profits c'est normal les
industries doivent faire du profit mais
elle sait pas occupée de nourrir les
Français s'occuper de ses profits et les
ministères d'agriculture successifs ont
laissé faire et donc maintenant que nous
avons perdu nous perdons notre vie notre
vignoble était le premier vignoble du
monde on est maintenant troisième
position derrière l'Espagne et l'Italie
l'arboriculture c'est une catastrophe
donc je dis à partir du moment où on a
perdu beaucoup de races animales
beaucoup de ça devient très compliqué ça
devient très compliqué on importe donc
pour le moment
il y a pas de sécurité alimentaire en
Europe est obligée d'apporter
massivement du Brésil d'Argentine
massivement
ça c'est ici quand même
compliqué c'est très compliqué quand
vous discutez avec les politiques ils
sont conscientes tout ça ou les
politiques ne discutent pas avec nous
vous cherchez un peu à discuter avec eux
il faudrait peut-être aller taper aux
portes mais je crois pas écouter on a je
dis ça on a fait un événement pour les
25 ans notre laboratoire on a invité les
vignerons les agriculteurs première
agriculteurs et on a invité les
politiques de la région personne
notre mère s'est réamsamen qui avait
quand même déjà
qu'il avait un déplacement on a demandé
aux députés au sénateur
il y en a un qui a accepté il a dit mais
une condition c'est vous qui faites le
discours parce que moi je veux pas je
veux pas dire des choses personne n'est
venu on est un petit laboratoire mais on
est reconnu sans avoir un péché
d'orgueil on est quand même reconnu dans
en France pour le pour plein de choses
pour enfin pour les vignerons pour les
céramiques pour le maraîchage on nous
demande et en fait quand il y a eu les
journées par exemple la COP 21 où il y a
eu des choses qui ont été dites sur le
sol en nombre de profils on a fait 12000
profils en France et à l'étranger dans
le monde profil de sol donc c'est quand
même une certaine connaissance
on fait des profils qu'on regarde et qui
sont pas analysés quand je dis pas
analysé dans notre laboratoire donc
quand on dit 12000 on peut mettre 15 15
16000 parce on fait des profils et on
regarde dans la parcelle si elle est en
pente on va prendre le dessus le dessus
de la parcelle parce qu'avec la pente et
le bas pour voir s'il y a de l'érosion
comment et après on va choisir quel sol
va être témoin du problème ou de du nom
problème de pour l'agriculteur donc on
en a vu beaucoup on a une certaine quand
même une certaine connaissance des sols
on ne fait on ne nous demande jamais
rien et la seule fois où le ministre de
l'Agriculture de l'époque donc monsieur
le folle qui voulait en fait faire
quelque chose avec nous et qu'il avait
donc dit
et bien en fait on nous a ça a été coupé
à la naissance on n'a pas pu le faire
des politiques
agricole
et c'est lui-même en disant qu'on avait
fait énormément pour pour l'agriculture
et que ça méritait mais c'est le seul
depuis et chaque fois vous faisait des
fois des questions pourquoi on nous
appelle pas alors qu'on ou que même si
on nous appelle pas mais enfin on nous
fait pas venir mais on pourrait demander
quand même des fois certains conseils
quoi enfin pas du tout
professeur de lycée agricole fait une
fake news sur Wikipédia en racontant
qu'on était le pénis ils sont prêts à
tout pour nous diffamer
c'est hallucinant on l'aura pas fait de
mal à ses propres de lycée ils ont
besoin de raconter qu'on est dû le pénis
et puis là je trouve que
je vais dire même si quelque chose qui
est absolument faux je trouve c'est
absolument c'est vraiment très grave
s'intéresser à ce qui se passe
exactement et le pénis ce qui s'est pas
le droit de s'intéresser à ça la
éventualité vous sauriez dans les ventes
mais notre planète enfin la France enfin
les sols de la France ils appartiennent
à tous les Français les revaloriser ça
va servir à tous les Français que vous
soyez droit de n'importe où vous soyez
même blanc noir jaune rouge c'est le
fait de monopoliser sur un parti
politique c'est absolument très très
gras la terre le sol il est à tout le
monde ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point ça nous a valu une
interdiction enfin c'est pas écrit mais
huit jours là on ne fait plus de cours
dans les collèges agricoles dans les
lycées agricoles on rentre plus dans les
chambres d'agriculture ça je trouve ça
très grave parce que
même si c'est pas c'est pas la raison
parce que il y a plusieurs chemins on
n'a pas la science infuse c'est pas tout
ce qu'on dit n'est pas forcément vrai
mais je pense que des étudiants des
jeunes doivent entendre d'autres
discours que le discours qui est
institué par les Chambres d'agriculture
ou par les collèges où on a des jeunes
qui quittent qui quittent des fois la
salle en disant oui mais mon père quand
il vous écoute je vous dites que vous
mettez pas de
d'azote que il faut plus labourer et ben
on va crever de faim et qui sortent et
qui sortent en quittant en disant c'est
n'importe quoi mais mais oui mais ça
c'est aussi le débat pourquoi ne donner
qu'une seule idée effectivement il y a
certains sols ça sera peut-être
compliqué mais pourquoi ne donner qu'une
seule idée empêcher d'autres personnes
de montrer qu'il y a des agricultures
dans le monde qui marche
marche très bien il fonctionne et qui
fonctionne qui donne des rendements qui
donnent des produits de qualité et qui
n'est pas le modèle que que l'on a nous
et je trouve ça grave parce que c'est
c'est aussi une quelque part une volonté
du pas une volonté mais une
désinformation d'idées d'autres idées de
culture de manière de voir le sol et je
trouve ça très grave pour une jeunesse
qui sera elle qui donnera le futur pour
pour ça et je trouve ça très grave
rajouter un mot
sur le fait qu'on nous dit femme comme
ça oui comme je te fais d'accord avec
Lydia c'est dommage pour les élèves
parce qu'ils auraient besoin pour rendre
des comptes que
on a beaucoup de mal à les emmener
devant un profil les élèves et c'est ça
nous arrivait quelquefois des profs ont
une courage de nous appeler on a fait un
profil d'en faire une tranchée tous les
élèves ça soit devant et on leur
explique on leur décrit en leur pose des
questions à ton avis pourquoi il y a ça
pourquoi cette galerie verticale sombre
dans le sol ils savent pas on leur dit
que c'est une galerie de ver de terre
les enfants ils sont passionnés ils sont
complètement passionnés quoi et on le
fait pas quoi la plupart des
enseignements on leur décrit même pas un
seul sur le plan physique chimique et
biologique c'est triste c'est triste
quand même question internet que pense
que pensent les invités du projet de
sécurité sociale de l'alimentation
portée par Bernard Friot et la
Confédération paysanne
la Confédération paysanne a parfaitement
raison elle est vraiment le le syndicat
agricole qui met le point sur la
sécurité alimentaire ce que font pas les
autres syndicats et ça là je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec eux il faut
absolument insister sur le notion de
sécurité alimentaire pour nous un état
il a plusieurs devoirs il doit nourrir
sa population il doit éduquer sa
population il doit transporter sa
population il doit soigner sa population
ça c'est des choses régaliennes et les
États en démissionné dans l'alimentation
de leur population et ça c'est une
santé ils ont bien démissionné aussi oui
qu'on vient de se taper de se taper
le roi était nu
on va prendre encore deux trois petites
questions les Bourguignons ont-ils un
potager un verger qui produit vous
faites quoi parce que tous ces beaux
conseils vous les appliquez pour vous ou
pas oui on les applique pour nous on est
on essaye
parce que on sait pas le problème c'est
que on bouge beaucoup pour aller faire
des profils chez les agriculteurs les
vignerons passer profils de sol chez les
agriculteurs les vignerons donc quand
c'est le moment de par exemple pour les
haricots verts comme c'est le moment de
les ramasser puis que vous êtes partis
pendant 10 jours 15 jours mais ils sont
pleins de films et on peut pas les
manger voilà ou la salade est montée
donc on dit servez-vous mais bien sûr
qu'on a on n'a pas de verger parce qu'on
habite au nord de la Bourgogne et que il
fait très froid donc on peut avoir par
exemple
la cerise c'est la petite cerise qui est
de la griotte qui qui peut pousser là
mais on n'est pas on n'est pas on n'est
pas on n'est pas du tout en zone en zone
en Bourgogne en revanche sur le plateau
de langues en revanche
on a voulu enfin là je vis vraiment j'ai
voulu parce que Claude ne voulait pas me
suivre et comme je suis quelqu'un qui ne
lâche pas j'ai dit
on conseille beaucoup il faut les
remercier parce que si on n'avait pas eu
les vignerons qui très tôt ont compris
que quand le sol était allé mieux
les vignes se portaient mieux et il y a
eu un vrai changement de complexité dans
leur vin et donc les vignerons nous ont
permis parce que en demandant qu'on
travaille pour eux nous ont permis de
tenir jusqu'à maintenant si on n'avait
pas eu les vignerons on ferait autre
chose mais pas ce laboratoire donc on va
les remercier mais quand on leur disait
arrêtez de défoncer vos sols arrêter de
retirer les caillots arrêter d'utiliser
du de l'herbicide même si votre vigne
est pas complètement propre à utiliser
votre en herbement permanent et on
entendait mais même en céramique en
céraliculture on entendait tout le monde
ça tout le temps ça oui bon d'accord
mais en fait vous pouvez lui donner des
conseils mais vous n'avez pas les mains
dans la terre et vous n'êtes pas des
agriculteurs vous n'êtes pas des
vignerons vous ne savez pas ce que c'est
cultivé un sol donc j'ai dit j'ai dit à
Claude écoute on peut pas être maraîcher
parce que on n'est jamais là donc ça va
être compliqué c'est relié c'est pas
notre truc notre et puis il faut
agresser les grandes surfaces on adore
le vin et bien en fait
on est on aime le vin et j'ai dit on va
surtout que on y allait quand même très
fort parce que les défonçage
les contes je lis défonçage il y a des
des
vignerons qui en fait ouvrent leur sol
retire tous les cailloux les blocs et la
colonne vertébrale il boit tout il remet
ça sur leur sol et ils disent bah tiens
j'ai des problèmes après donc on leur
expliquait que c'est pas comme ça qu'il
fallait faire et donc là j'ai dit à
Claude on va
mettre en application tout ce qu'on
conseille
au vignerons et on va pas on va pas
prendre bon on aurait pu on a cherché
des des sols qui permettaient de faire
une agriculture et des sols qui avaient
des vocations et là je prends ce mot-là
parce qu'en fait l'agriculture à l'heure
actuelle avec tout ce qu'on leur permet
de mettre tel produit tel fertilisant
telle céréale l'irrigation on fait
croire qu'on peut faire de bons produits
partout et les sols ont des vocations et
ça en Europe et dans beaucoup d'endroits
on a oublié cette notion là un sol
céréalier fera du mauvais vin et un seul
pour le vin
c'est exagéré mais enfin une mauvaise et
donc on est allé à Cahors 35% de pente
beaucoup de cailloux
30 cm de sol
pas d'irrigation
pas d'eau vraiment disponible et on a
dit on va faire de la vigne et on vend
notre vin voilà
est disponible sur Internet
question
simplement pour dire quand en fait quand
vous êtes consultant dans beaucoup de
gens ne le disaient et puis même
d'autres quand même parce qu'on côtoie
quand même d'autres consultants en fait
on leur dit mais vous avez pas fait vos
preuves vous pouvez toujours dire ah ben
défonce pas mais le sol mais pas ne tue
pas l'herbe parce que il va y avoir de
la concurrence ne fait pas signe fait
pas ça et là on a dit il faut il faut
qu'on dise que c'est possible c'est
possible sans herbicide sans on utilise
que du compost on n'utilise pas de
fertilisation on n'utilise pas de levure
qu'on achète du Comet c'est notre sol
qui va donner ce vin là on y on ira pas
on rajoute pas de sucre enfin voilà
alors je vais vous lire la question elle
est un peu péchue vous y répondez vous y
répondez pas mais je la je vais la lire
quand même vu alors question des gens vu
qu'on est en face de pure anthroposophe
il y a pas moyen d'avoir des infos sur
le financement de leur société et le
parasitage des subventions partout il y
en a point d'interrogation donc c'est
une question agressive ou pas agressive
oui elle est agressive mais on n'est pas
entreposage on fait pas faire de la
biodynamie à tout le monde on n'a jamais
eu une seule subvention bien au
contraire donc je comprends pas la
question on est des agriculteurs qui
utilisent des produits aussi parce que
on ne peut pas changer c'est d'ailleurs
un des problèmes du signe il n'y a pas
une aide des agriculteurs qui veulent
changer et là de façon étatique ça ira
très mal parce que ça ira mal pourquoi
parce qu'à un seul qui a été gavé de
produits
vous lui supprimez du jour au lendemain
et on peut pas le faire du jour au
lendemain il faut l'accompagner il faut
vous le supprimer du jour au lendemain
les rendements se cassent la figure
c'est l'agriculteur ben ce pan donc
c'est pas comme ça qu'on va
révolutionner là il faut y aller tout
doucement et je prends toujours cet
exemple c'est quelqu'un qui a été qui
est malade qui a été perfusé pendant
longtemps du jour au lendemain on lui
retire les pères et on lui dit tu vas
faire un 100 m et bien nous sommes ils
sont dans cette situation là si on les
accompagne pas pour faire un changement
petit à petit c'est à dire on va
diminuer les doses d'engrais on va
diminuer l'utilisation d'herbicides ou
de fongicides parce que la plante le sol
ira de mieux en mieux et en fait pour
finir d'aller mais on n'est pas on n'est
pas des des anthroposants on a lu
effectivement Steiner on a lu aussi
d'autres littérature agricoles et
on est on fait partie on n'a pas de
groupe de la suite de la question il y a
il y a il y a pas moyen d'avoir des
infos sur le financement de leur société
et on a pas de société
le notre laboratoire est né de
nos deniers personnels voilà et quand on
a quitté l'INRA parce qu'on sait qui on
était tous les deux à l'INRA on avait
fait quelques économies on s'est
défonctionnarisé du jour au lendemain
tous les deux et on a monté notre
laboratoire au départ on était dans la
cave on a acheté du matériel d'occasion
et on a jamais eu les banques n'ont pas
suivi on a eu énormément de problèmes
avec les banques donc je vois pas
pourquoi on nous demande quel est notre
financement le financement c'est notre
travail
quotidien nos analyses j'en profite en
vous me lancez sur la deuxième question
comment faire pour financer le chemin le
changement de pratique des agriculteurs
et compenser la baisse de rendement
pendant la transition il faut que les
tasses mettent entre les deux
voilà on a détruit les sols il va
falloir les restaurer ça va coûter de
l'argent mais bien sûr il faut des
subventions il faut les aider soit par
des subventions soit avoir une politique
peut-être pour ouvrir certains plutôt
que de faire du maïs irrigué on peut
peut-être travailler avec les sorgho le
sorgho au niveau de l'alimentation des
maîtres maître mais l'État doit si on
dit que l'État doit subvenir à à
l'indépendance agricole mais s'il
n'aimait pas une volonté c'est pas les
agriculteurs qui arriveront tout seul
c'est pas vrai
quels sont les trois bouquins qui vous
pouvez recommander à notre communauté
trois livres que on voudrait
notre dernier livre je le recommande pas
forcément d'accord
la planète brûle quand la maison quand
la maison brûle pardon
Claude
et donc en explique la destruction des
sols la pollution de l'eau la pollution
de l'air la destruction de la
biodiversité et la destruction de
l'humanité passait une vraie destruction
de l'humanité il y a une violence qui
monte dans l'humanité très très
inquiétante après avoir décrit ces
choses un peu triste maison brûle on
explique pourquoi on fait rien parce que
pour moi c'est la plus grande question
philosophique du 21e siècle pourquoi
nous ne faisons rien face à une
catastrophe écologique qui arrive à
toute allure et donc nous avons émis 10
raisons 10 hypothèses on n'est pas on
dit pas qu'on est exhaustif mais on émet
10 hypothèses
comme pour expliquer pour expliquer
cette au bout de 27 toujours pas pris la
moindre décision voilà donc on a c'est
des questions à la fois financières de
passionnés le délire religieux de la
technologie enfin il y a plein de choses
l'explosion démographique qu'on n'arrive
pas à contrôler donc la surface agricole
par habitant ne cesse de baisser bon
voilà il y a 10 raisons pour lequel pour
lequel on ne bouge pas mais c'est notre
parce qu'il y a on a il est il est en
vente et on a de temps en temps des
mails qui est enfin des des questions
qui sont pas qui sont pas très enfin qui
qui qui va y arriver en disant bon bah
rester dans votre dans ce que vous savez
faire c'est à dire le sol mais pourquoi
vous avez dépensé dites philosophiques
ou des pensées mais toutes dans un livre
on a le droit de dire ce que l'on pense
par rapport à ça c'est pas on va pas
rester dans notre effectivement on
travaille sur l'agriculture mais on a
visité quand même beaucoup de pays et
par exemple on vient de Mayotte je veux
dire c'est un véritable drame c'est
c'est une poudrière et on est en France
et les gens ne je crois ne réalisent pas
ce qui se passe au niveau des sols dans
ces pays quand on voit la violence qui
arrive à l'heure les guerres et tout on
le met toujours sur le côté politique
mais quand on regarde c'est souvent des
problèmes de sécheresse puis d’eau c'est
des problèmes de malnutrition de sols
qui sont en très mauvais état et très
souvent c'est des gens qui viennent pour
pouvoir gagner de l'argent pour pouvoir
nourrir leurs familles ils envoient
l'argent pour pour ça et en fait on le
met toujours sur le côté politique mais
quand on gratte il y a un problème de
survie du sol de l'eau de donc on est
dans un monde qui est d'une violence
effectivement il y a des agrivés et des
agressivités tous ces tous ces gens qui
quittent leur pays quitter son pays moi
je j'en parle pour d'autres raisons mes
parents ils ont quitté leur pays quand
il y a eu la guerre ils ont perdu leur
maison et en fait ils sont retrouvés en
France on a eu des conditions de vie
très difficiles mais parents ont
souffert de quitter leur pays on quitte
pas son pays comme ça parce qu'on a
envie de partir il y a toujours une
raison on les gens disent c'est parce
que ils viennent chercher de l'argent
[Musique]
donc trois bouquins conseillés à notre
communauté Lydia
avait un bouquin des bouquins qui ont
marqué votre vie qui qui ont marqué mais
depuis
un mois je
[Musique]
il y en a un qui m'a mais j'étais jeune
on n'avait pas de livre à la maison on
écoutait pas la musique mes parents
étaient vraiment trop pauvres mais à
l'école on arrivait donc peut-être que
c'est un peu à l'eau de rose mais le
grand môle parce que ça m'a fait rêver
dans ce livre
un qui m'a alors maintenant qui m'a
interpellé c'est
c'est le livre de
du pape je ne suis pas de
François qui dit des choses ça m'a
interpellé parce que la religion était
pas pas vraiment là-dessus et en fait il
parle du sol il parle aussi de dire que
cet argent qui il faut pas il faut pas
manger avec le diable il dénonce aussi
la même mise de ces de ces
multinationales et je trouve que c'est
c'est intéressant parce que
c'est plus qu'intéressant c'est pas
c'est une un pape qui dit ça mais ça m'a
interpellé et un autre
alors c'est pas un lit c'est pas un
livre de lecture mais il y en a un autre
qui m'a fait rêver quand je reviens et
je pense que si je j'ai travaillé après
en
continuant mes études en travaillant
parce que j'ai travaillé très très tôt
donc j'ai continué mes mon père m'a mis
au travail très tôt
on sortait pas on n'avait pas de voiture
on avait et
à l'école le lundi matin les gens on
avait une quand on était en 6e 6e 5e
mais surtout en 6e le lundi matin on
avait une
professeur pardon de sciences naturelles
qui disait et bien si vous partez à la
campagne surtout au printemps vous
ramenez des plantes et on va les
déterminer et la flore Bonnier m'a fait
rêver pendant des années et c'est un
livre qui m'est cher vous avez un ami
imaginaire vous croyez quelque chose une
religion ou quoi que ce soit
j'ai l'impression alors c'est peut-être
une je vais détourner la je vais
détourner votre question
c'est pas sympa non mais quand vous
dites un imaginaire
oui je dirais un ami imaginaire parce
que
je reviens à ce que j'étais j'ai
l'impression qu'en fait quand on
travaille avec les agriculteurs quand il
se passe quelque chose j'ai l'impression
que je suis branchée à quelque chose que
ça me traverse c'est je parle mais c'est
pas que moi qui parle et c'est une
sensation que j'ai très souvent alors on
peut l'appeler comme vous voulez Claude
trois bouquins
naturels ou il décrit toutes les espèces
qui disparaissent à ça m'a complètement
secoué ensuite Rachel Carson dans le
printemps silence ça c'est deux livres
qui m'ont complètement et puis un roman
que j'adorais qui est la racine du ciel
de Romain Gary oui il dit ces choses
magnifiques quand on a plus quand on
aura plus d'éléphant liberté donc il a
il fait une relation entre la
destruction de la nature et la perte de
la liberté humaine qui m'a beaucoup
beaucoup bouleversé aussi Claude est-ce
que vous avez un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
une bouteille à la mer quelque chose qui
va rester sur internet je pense qu'il
veut je pense que je pense que un livre
ou un guide de jardinage sera beaucoup
plus utile pour toute la jeunesse qui
arrive l'art de savoir simplement ce
médias des choses simples beaucoup plus
utile que toutes ces cops font dépenses
énormément d'argent et on prend une
décision et je conseille aux jeunes de
s'intéresser au jardinage c'est un c'est
un bonheur de voir pousser ses légumes
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
c'est faire confiance à la nature parce
qu'on leur dit je crois que en fait leur
donner un espoir parce que quand même la
jeunesse c'est compliqué pour eux en ce
moment donc peut-être ce que dit clones
mais je crois aussi croire qu'il y a
autre chose que
autre chose des choses beaucoup plus
humaine plus sur la sensibilité je
trouve qu'on oublie la poésie les poètes
ont dit beaucoup de choses on oublie
cette poésie ce côté un peu
oui plus spirituel plus
oui plus de poésie plus faire confiance
à la nature et croire que c'est que rien
n'est fini à partir du moment où on veut
quelque chose on peut le faire rien
n'est fini une dernière question qui
vient juste de tomber d'ailleurs
et je vais la poser parce que c'est une
accusation que penses-tu des accusations
d'escroquerie sur leurs analyses de Sud
fait-elle distance sans venir sur place
facturer très cher
sans venir à distance je relis le truc
que pense-t-il des accusations
d'escroquerie sur leurs analyses de sol
faites à distance sans venir sur place
facturer très cher le mec qui raconte
n'importe quoi on ne fait pas d'analyses
à distance ça ça s'appelle analyse de
terre c'est ce que font les laboratoires
l'analyse de sol en place une fois que
l'analyse de soleil a été faite on peut
nous demander pour l'activité biologique
qui nous envoie un échantillon d'un seul
qu'on a déjà étudié mais on ne fait
jamais de on vient on va toujours sur le
terrain
ce qu'on a fait on était sur le terrain
c'est très rare alors est-ce qu'il pense
moi je voilà clone dit ça est-ce qu'il
pense à on travaille on a on nous a
demandé de travailler pour une
jardinerie pour faire des kits de
d'analyse de sol pas d'analyse avec
l'activité biologique mais il y a très
très peu de gens qui la font et alors
peut-être que là en comparaison de de
d'une analyse on voit on sait ce qui est
fait effectivement je suis d'accord on
est plus cher tout à fait d'accord mais
en fait on apporte pas la tout à fait la
même chose c'est-à-dire qu'à partir de
là on va conseiller quel type de légumes
ils peuvent mettre ne pas faire signe ne
pas faire ça nos analyses de sol quand
on va alors les gens qui décrivent ça
qui décrivent ça on l'a entendu alors
donc on nous le bassine sans arrêt sur
Internet et même ailleurs je veux dire
quand vous vous déplacez et donc chez
l'agriculteur que vous faites un profil
que vous passez une heure une heure et
demie avec l'agriculteur pour lui parler
de son paysage aussi parce que ça on en
parle pas la vocation de son sol essayez
de lui faire comprendre que ben si il
change pas ça va être compliqué après on
ramène de la terre
on analyse les horizons avec une
activité biologique toute la chimie le
type d'argile qu'il a après en fonction
de tous les tests terrains qu'on a fait
on va faire un une ordonnance on va leur
dire vous allez non et ben une
moi j'appelle ça une préconisation donc
en travail
et on va y passer
au total deux jours et demi avec notre
travail de d'expert plus un technicien
qui fait les analyses de laboratoire et
une secrétaire avec une entreprise 100
et bien le prix le prix si c'était si
cher vu le nombre que l'on a fait je
pense qu'on serait
on serait on aurait plus on aurait
d'autres choses donc je c'est toujours
la critique parce que l'analyse d'un
agriculteur qui va prendre à la carrière
qui renvoie 30 cm de sol ou même 40 on
va lui donner un conseil en disant vous
manquez de ça et ça on lui dit pas vous
pouvez continuer ou pas continuer et
tout effectivement c'est nettement moins
cher que nous mais c'est mais c'est
évident il y a pas de discussion mais ça
n'a rien à voir
dans des études après on la Tamise avec
des robots nous l'activité biologique
vous pouvez pas faire sécher le sol ça
fait mourir les microbes donc tout est
tamisé à la main ça ça n'a rien à voir
c'est comme si vous vous comparez
et je vais finir parce que tu me coupes
j'ai pas fini et en plus l'analyse une
analyse complète c'est le sol c'est le
premier outil pour un agriculteur
l'agriculteur et vous avez un
agriculteur qui va vous dire j'ai un
argile au calcaire c'est une question
qui a été posée par un minion j'ai un
limon calcaire j'ai un sol le sablo limo
mais qu'est-ce que ça veut dire au
niveau de ça et souvent ces agriculteurs
qui nous accusent ou s'évignons qui nous
accuse de chair d'être cher ils ont des
machines qui coûtent des des centaines
de mille
euros 1500 euros
pour connaître son patrimoine découvrir
en face qui sont seuls et comment il
fonctionne voilà donc on va le dire mais
et ces gens c'est ce monde agricole est
prêt à mettre des prix incroyables que
ce soit sur leur matériel en disant j'ai
besoin d'un tracteur de tant de chevaux
mais quand vous avez un sol qui est
complètement compacté effectivement
et une analyse de sol qui permet de
connaître son sol qui permet de faire à
la longue sur trois ans ou 6 ans des
économies d'engrais de de produits
herbicides et tout je trouve qu'il
faudrait quand même qu'on fasse le
calcul quoi
messieurs dames bonsoir
Claude il dit à bourguignon merci d'être
venu nous voir et bonne soirée merci
[Musique]